so two nights ago I'm standing on 43rd
and 7th Avenue in Times Square with this
uh with this guy Lou gradkowski over
here and we heard what sound it sounded
to me kind of like a whip crack or a
lightning strike like lightning strike
like it was weird and I knew it was a
weird sound and and I immediately I look
around no one's reacting we got cops
everywhere and I'm like okay that was
weird that was a weird noise
but you know quick assessment of
everything I don't see anything in my
vicinity I don't see anything going on
no Panic no police action everything
seems fine or whatever we'll go back
inside we're in this party we go
downstairs turns out apparently a Jihadi
with a machete struck two cops and then
they shot him and that was the noise we
heard on the South End of Times Square
that was crazy and I saw Matt Bender uh
Progressive uh personality tweeting
because he was I guess he was outside
the perimeter something happened and
then I was like yo what time was this
and then he was like 15 minutes ago and
I was like dude we heard that gunshot
that's crazy so I don't know what's
going to happen with 2023 but like
within an hour of the Year about being
about to start that's what happens and I
was kind of surprised I was like Jihadi
action that's that's like a throwback
you know that's not really what we've
been seeing for the past few years it's
been all like far left far right
but let's get into it we got this big
story so I'll tell you I got another
story for you I'm in Savannah Georgia
and I'm waiting in line at Leopold's Ice
Cream for everybody who knows that and
I'm talking to Shane Cashman about a
potential story we're working on and
then you know he's gets on his phone I'm
standing there then all of a sudden I
see this story about Andrew Tate getting
arrested and then Shane walks up and I'm
like did you hear and he goes yes like
we instantly knew we were talking about
the story about Andrew Tate
so the claim was that a pizza box got
him caught which is nonsense and a lie
the whole thing was a hoax we don't know
exactly what's going on he's been
arrested and detained on allegations of
trafficking some people on the right are
saying it's worse than anyone realizes
some people on the left are saying he's
a human trafficker but we're gonna break
this down and we're gonna call out there
is a prominent trans activist who has
been spreading outright Diss and
misinformation using corporate press
going before Congress and just outright
in the most exaggerated way making up
fake news and the media just buys it
they buy right into it so we got a lot
of talk about that and so much more
we've got the fauci files Elon Musk
Biden was ordered a few months ago to
release communication so this this may
uh play into what we're seeing with the
factory files we'll talk about that
stuff too we've got Kevin McCarthy he's
moved into the speaker's suite for the
speaker of the house but uh was it looks
at nine people nine nine members of
Congress
good we'll see what happens before we
get started my friends head over to
nightwatchpro.com and pick up your 2023
4K Night Watch Pro binoculars up to 60
off uh it's it's a really simple pitch
ladies and gentlemen these are a
low-cost consumer grade infrared night
vision it's not going to be like the
crazy military grade stuff I got to tell
you if you've got 20 grand to drop and
you want to check those out 15 to 20.
yeah maybe you get those but if you want
to spend a couple hundred bucks you can
get these they allow you to clearly see
in the darkness they got a three inch
large HD display rechargeable lithium
battery all night viewing 4K video 32
gig SD card included for storing photos
and videos it looks pretty cool I was
actually uh fairly impressed by by the
quality so I actually have you know me
and Luke we have the super high grade
like actual military grade 9 night
vision that stuff will change your life
but if you're just trying to see in the
dark you want to get you want to film
stuff at night these really do work and
I think they're only a couple hundred
bucks
you can get them yeah 200 bucks so this
is nightwatchpro.com from Pepper's Peak
shout out thanks for sponsoring the show
check them out 60 off but don't forget
to go to timcast.com become a member and
support our work directly we're gonna
have a members all members only
uncensored show coming up for you later
tonight that I can only imagine will be
particularly spicy to kick off the New
Year there are a lot of stories
um that we'll end up talking about I
mean we we have the story right here on
the front page of timcast.com the
execution of a transgender identifying
person the first in U.S history and I
oppose a death penalty so we're going to
talk about that in a few other things
probably a lot more in the members only
show so become a member go to
timcast.com click join us and we've got
a bunch of other stuff in the works too
we're setting up this coffee shop as I
mentioned so people can come and
actually hang out in a physical space
where we play these shows where we have
comedy events music events we're going
to have games we're gonna have Ian's
Crystal Cove where you can watch movies
and chill out and there's crystals
everywhere and then we're gonna start
building more of these to create
physical space tubs where people of like
mind can hang out we're going to put it
molan labe in the front window we're
going to put American flags in the
window we're not going to cower and be
in in fear from antifa no no we're gonna
we're gonna put up the come and take it
signs and flags and all that stuff and
we're gonna start pushing back by
creating a space where all we have to do
is hang out and share a cup of coffee
maybe I think we're working on a liquor
license too so um we've got plans for
setting up a bunch of these all over the
place and I'm really excited for that
with your support we will do that so
become a member at timcast.com smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
oh boy we have an awesome guest tonight
we have Haya rycheck of Libs of tick
tock hanging out hi thanks for having me
here yeah do you want to introduce
yourself so my name is claia and I am
the creator of lives of tech talk mostly
known on Twitter but we're on all social
channels what researchers too busy
focused on your on your audio my
apologies okay
um and yeah basically what we do is we
hold up a mirror to the left and show
people what they themselves are saying
and they just can't stand to see it you
did your first interview with Tucker
Carlson was that a week ago right yeah a
week ago and now you are doing more
public forward-facing interviews and
conversations and here you are sitting
here with us I'm I'm grateful that
you're here and you know so much about
this it's really interesting how
we should definitely talk about your
your origin story too because you've
become one of the most important
investigative journalists by simply
watching their videos and then showing
them to people I I've talked to you
right right in front of you for people
who can't say we have uh the genderqueer
book Ian bought that and one and we
talked about how it's like I don't want
to give this person money but people but
we need to we need proof I've talked to
so many people about this stuff and
they're like there's no way that's true
we were talking earlier and I said so
much radical nonsense has happened over
the past couple of years the average
person who hasn't been paying attention
will never believe it unless you show
them exactly yeah and this is this this
is in every single Public School almost
I mean it's it's everywhere and if I
show it this they'll probably take the
stream down
um yeah there are if you post images
from this on Instagram they're gonna
take it down that's right even on
searches like Google searches I try and
find it and I don't find any of the
stuff that you would not want in schools
showing up publicly so I think it's a
combination of they don't want people to
know it exists because it will upend a
lot of the plans of these individuals
but more importantly it is shocking to
the average person it's absolutely
shocking and that's the best way really
to educate people and to raise awareness
is to just show them the straight up
facts like I always show images of this
and I'm like this is in your kid's
school like you need to do something
about this and they say to me they're
like maybe but like what like one or two
and I'm like dude like come on like no
like I'm not going to come out here and
claim 50 000 schools have it or anything
like that but we keep hearing from more
and more parents at more and more school
meetings it's been hundreds at this
point it could be more and it's not just
this one right it's all the other books
it's all the other weird stuff yeah I
have a list I mean there's there's
hundreds of books I think it was asrin
Omani who came on was that who was yeah
yeah she had a stack of all these books
crazy stuff five children's books so
thanks for joining us this will be a lot
of fun
yes it's going to be great and then of
course Luke gradkowski's here it's not
just that they're going to take it down
if you post it on Instagram the White
House and the FBI is going to take down
your account if you talk about it which
is absolutely crazy and this is why I
think sanity is not statistical that's a
quote from 1984 it's one of my favorite
books also Lex Friedman's uh book that
he's going to be finally reading uh and
I think our modern society is definitely
reflecting this quote and that's why I
made this shirt with Lady Liberty having
better days which you could get on
thebestpoliticalshorts.com because
because you do that's why I'm here thank
you for having me this should be a great
conversation real quick someone
superintended already it's really really
good 2023 my butt this is 2020 part 4
the nope hope
oh geez doesn't it feel like that hey
buddy hey buddy hey everybody welcome
back I hope you had a fantastic couple
weeks I did it was really nice
um you know let's just get to it I'm Ian
you know me you love me whether you want
to or not what's up what's up Kyle good
to see you what's happening Serge and I
am Serge I had a long day it's been a
bunch of delays difficult flights uh you
know you guys probably know exactly how
it is if you're living in Mountain West
it's been ridiculous dude this this was
one of the most brutal holiday travel
Seasons everybody knows I'm sure we
spent a day at the airport he slept on
the ground on on like mattresses that
they had some blankets thank God they
had mattresses we saw those pictures
coming out of Southwest with all the
luggage it was crazy
did they find our luggage our equipment
oh yeah it's all been here oh it's here
already
our equipment from turning point when
we're leaving Phoenix oh really they
lost it sounds was there any Biden
officials there no no I was gonna say
maybe San Martin but you guys are all
men so I don't think he's into that kind
of luggage no no yeah
right there let's uh let's let's jump to
this first story let's get into it we
have this uh Twitter thread from Jessie
single he says because she is very on
Twitter and has Harvard in her bio Cara
bio is seen by journalists with no
subject matter expertise as a serious
voice on anti-disinformation counters
counter extremism stuff she spreads
disinformation all the time like
seemingly every new viral Lefty rumor
the story My Friends Andrew Tates arrest
so as I mentioned you know in the intro
I'm in Savannah
we're in line at Leopold's if Savannah
people know what I'm talking about
tourist ice cream it was really good by
the way but the line's massive Shane
Cashman is there he did this excellent
story on Carrie Lake's election lawsuit
he was there you got you really got to
read the story if you haven't I tweeted
about it it's on timcast.com but anyway
we're talking about we're talking about
Andrew Tate 10 minutes later he's like
he's like walking around on his phone he
walks back over after I pull up Twitter
I see the story breaking and then I'm
just like dude did you hear and he's
like yeah what's going on like Andrew
take gets arrested for human trafficking
and so then all of a sudden the story
emerges he did this video in response to
Greta tunberg where he's smoking a cigar
and he's eating pizza and he says get me
some pizzas make sure the boxes aren't
recycled Alejandra carabayo a trans
woman posts Romanian authorities needed
proof that Andrew Tate was in the
country so they reportedly used his
social media posts his ridiculous video
yesterday featured a pizza from a
Romanian Pizza chain Jerry's Pizza
confirming he was in the country this is
absolutely epic this is outright
nonsense fact but the crazy thing to me
was when I saw that going viral I was
immediately like why would they need a
video of him eating pizza he flew in
he's on the Manifest when when there
when why they're flying private or
otherwise they provide a list of names
of people under in the country he'd have
to have a passport unless he like bribed
somebody but even then it's as if like
they needed proof he was in the country
to arrest them why would they need proof
use in the country either he's in the
country and they go arrest him or he's
not so what was the point of this tweet
just to make up a lie to post some
insane lie and then karabio says not
only did Greta tunberg destroy Andrew
Tate with her tweet she made him so
angry he inadvertently tipped off from
any authorities of his presence in
Romania with his lame comeback video the
dude has a complex in Romania he's got
he's got a massive building complex
this is this this is uh it's a hoax
but it's not just this one Story Jesse
single also points out car Bio Car bio
helps spread the rumor that the Club Q
shooting had a connection to anti-lgbtq
rhetoric still unproven and then that
story went viral like oh this person was
anti-lgbtq then it turns out the person
was non-binary and he says the same deal
with the power station attacks which
remain unsolved authorities are still
seeking a motive car bio gets viral
attention by suggesting some of the
attacks had to do with drag queen Story
Hour the crazy thing is this person this
trans activist speaks before Congress
literally just takes a random story and
then says oh it's because they hate
trans people and the media runs with it
this person is also cited as a Online
safety and disinformation expert so not
just does the media run with with all
the lies but they also they also use
Alejandra to
to talk about safety and and online
discipline and disinformation and it's
just bizarre that this person just
spreads all these hoaxes and I'll note
that these hoaxes actually have have
real world world effects those the other
two
um hoaxes that that were spread they
actually blame them on on me so I'm
getting tons of hate because you know
they're they said that that I caused the
the power outages because I posted about
that drag show and it has nothing to do
with drug right and it wasn't just me
getting hate there were other you know
other other big accounts also getting
getting hate for posting about those
events so this person is out here
spreading lies and we're we're getting a
lot of hate for it and it's and then the
media cites them and it's just totally
it's totally not true I want to talk
about Andrew Tate a little bit but I
first have to ask why do you think it is
that they hate you so much
I think it's a really big threat to them
when they see their own words being
being sad and being spread the way that
that it is but no no no I'm sorry that's
what I don't understand
a person says a thing and then you go
hey look this person said a thing and
they're like stop stop wait wait what
well not just that also they want to go
viral on Tech talk the reason they make
tick tocks is to go viral so they want
these videos to be shared and spread and
they want a ton of views but just not by
us do you like take it out of context
and just post the worst never I I I
don't edit the videos yeah do you just
take like tiny clips of longer videos
and post like the most only if it's like
a 10 minute video you should have
responded to Tim's question by saying
you're a top G and there's a war on top
teas going on right now is that is that
what Tate says that's what people in the
comments are going after yeah he's
making vague kind of gestures uh someone
is tweeting for him obviously because
he's still being detained for 30 days in
a Romanian jail so a lot of people don't
understand how how things work in
Romania they think it's very similar to
how it works in the United States it's
actually not the case I want to kind of
bring them back to what's happening with
Andrew Tate because in Romania you have
to be accused of a crime you don't need
probable cause police could hold you for
24 hours and of course investigate and
check out your premises and have search
warrants but but something very odd is
happening here because number one
there's footage of all of this being
released to the general public that's
extremely strange that's not standard
protocol especially when it comes to uh
the raid and the private rooms and the
private you know stuff that Andrew Tate
has in in one of his house I think there
was five search warrants on five
different homes that were being served
all of those are on video available for
the general public to see which is again
something that routinely doesn't happen
and uh is is not supposed to be going on
during during an ongoing investigation
and after those 24 hours a judge gets to
decide if he's going to be holding
someone a longer a judge could actually
hold someone for 180 days he decided to
hold Andrew Tate for 30 days and there's
a lot of fake news there's a lot of
disinformation we still don't know
exactly what happened here we're still
waiting for a lot of the information to
come forward but the media is running
with just absolute nonsensical bull crap
hit pieces and and they're talking about
oh there's large sums of money there was
some makeshift weapons I mean yeah the
guy was debanked yeah the guy has a high
profile of course they're going to have
cash around of course they're going to
have security of course you're going to
have weapons so it looks like looking at
the corporate media we're reporting on
this that they have a particular
narrative this is why they had to run
with the pizza box story and again the
Romanian authorities had to intervene on
that story and say specifically hey this
is inaccurate it was in the pizza box
that led to his arrest but uh there was
also someone who tweeted a couple months
ago saying that Andrew Tate was going to
be arrested at the end of 2023 because
the Romanian government was facing a lot
of pressure by the American authorities
and this brings me to the latest story
of what's happening in the Virgin
Islands which I hope we get to talk
about in just a little bit which is also
just as eye-opening just as crazy uh no
no the US Virgin Islands attorney
general uh officially sued uh Chase uh
Chase Bank for being a part of this
larger trafficking operation of Epstein
and breaking the rules not reporting and
helping him Aid an Abed in his
international trafficking or operation
she was just fired by the way just
moments ago and the Biden Jill and Joe
Biden just flew there just flew there
and the U.S Virgin Islands are also
asking for a huge sum of money from the
federal government so all of that is
also happening right now which is just
crazy look as it pertains to Andrew Tate
I can just I just gotta say look I don't
know innocent until proven guilty let's
let's see the evidence I've heard clips
of him saying things that are shockingly
offensive but you know people ought to
be offensive but you know he talks about
having women do cam work for him because
they love him having having women who
don't love him doing cam work and then
demanding money I'll just say this man
if these allegations are true they
better throw the book at him right after
they finish that Maxwell case and we
figure out who is she was trafficking
into you know tits at the bottom of the
list
we've been sitting here for a few months
waiting for that Epstein Client List and
so priorities guys you know don't don't
jump the gun on this one I know Andrew
Tate big fish to fry but we're still
working on the Maxwell yeah yeah we're
so working on prince Andrew Bill Gates
Kevin Spacey uh Bill Clinton there's
still a lot of other people that we got
to we'll get to Andrew
Epstein was one of Maxwell's clients she
would facilitate girls to different guys
and Epstein was one of them I mean it
goes deep on Elaine Maxwell Robert
Maxwell or Dad I just watched a
documentary on her over the over the
holiday you think she was the one who's
actually the enduring master and she is
so connected that they're not afraid
she's going to talk and they're just put
her in this this cushy home detention
center where she's sitting whatever is
it POS so are you saying then in your
opinion Epstein was actually like
her play thing and she was giving him
the things he wanted but she was
actually in charge yeah and then when he
gets busted they're like he's gonna talk
and then for sure they thought he was
going to talk and in my opinion what
happened was her dad Robert Maxwell
Billy hundreds of millions of dollars
worth she would go around and hang out
with him everywhere he was her money boy
they lived the rich lifestyle he was
always her advisor he dies immediately
she hooks up with another money boy and
it's Jeffrey Epstein and she just ties
her life in with this guy and starts
feeding him young women because that's
what he likes well I just I just got
like that you know unless he's still
alive you know if these allegations
against Andrew Tate about human
trafficking are true like wow I'm gonna
be really angry in in 18 months when
they finally get through that entire
list that Luke just read off now let's
be real they're jumping the list well
now I'm offended it's like come on man
look all of these other people who are
very powerful and very wealthy who are
connected to Epstein we want the Epstein
Client List instead they're like oh you
know I Andrew Tate yeah he's he's
trafficking it's like oh all right well
before if we're gonna if we're gonna be
in that subject matter so who is who is
really pushing this narrative right this
person Alejandra carobayo mocking Andrew
Tate and all that stuff it's like hey
that's really great but anybody who
cares about trafficking is going to be
talking about Epstein or Maxwell Maxwell
keep it on Maxwell I think she's alive
she's definitely the ringleader I mean I
can't say definitely because I don't
know but if you look at like Maria
Farmer's you know memory of the thing is
GUI Lane at the very center Elaine's the
money girl she's the the party animal
you know she just
follow the money have you ever seen
those conspiracies that Jeffrey Epstein
is still alive oh yeah yeah but there's
a conspiracy for everything yeah I don't
know what do you what do you think Luke
there's a there's a nice photo of him on
the uh maybe of him sorry excuse me of
of Drone footage of that island that
made me want to go there particularly
but uh that's oh that's a whole
different story I I think it's feasible
I think right now with how much the
government has lied how much they have
actually just screwed over the American
people with just how long they've been
running an international trafficking
operation 30 plus years that we know of
like anything anything's possible
exactly so right now Andrew trade is
also facing 20 years in jail if
convicted so he's still going to be
detained he might be detained even
longer from here uh and we're going to
find out exactly what's happening here
but but reading the Romanian kind of
press release on this that they're
talking about him being a lover boy
they're talking about him telling women
that he's going to be falling in love
with them and that allegedly is a crime
because he made them work on on an only
fan site so again if that's what they're
going after him for that's extremely
strange if there's going to be bigger
Bombshells obviously if someone does
something wrong they should be punished
for it obviously but a lot of people are
saying that this is too coincidental
that he has empowered a lot of people he
had he has made a lot of people think
independently and therefore now he's
being silenced and punished he's playing
along with that whoever is on his
Twitter account playing along with that
kind of narrative is he truly that bad
person that the media is making him out
to be well only time will tell but a lot
of people are saying it's very
suspicious that they're only
predominantly focusing and going after
him at this time uh when he's such an
important figure for so many important
people his brother too Tristan is
Tristan no but but the question is this
I mean one I don't trust the machine
when it pulls things like this uh well
I'll put his way innocent until proven
guilty I don't care any time but with
Julian Assange they make up fake sex
crimes against them which have been
washed away like the investigation's
over there's nothing to it but now he's
being held on Espionage charges so so
they were just trying to find a reason
to stop Julian from being able to do
work not and Andrew takes very different
he's a guy who goes on shows and talks
about all of his women and how he does
these things it's very very different
but I'm right away like you made it tell
me you're so concerned about human
trafficking meanwhile Maxwell's Client
List is just nowhere to be found sorry I
don't believe it look I I I think maybe
they don't like the guy maybe there's
something to it maybe the accusations
could be true all that stuff fine but
I'm gonna lean towards doubt because
they Maxwell's there dude I just watched
The Client List and then go after him
and traffickers if you're really
concerned about him and try to watch the
50-minute uh Jimmy Dore episode with
this girl Whitney Webb Whitney Webb is
the Nexus of the Epstein Maxwell
information if you want to find out she
just wrote a book on it and it's
basically about one nation under
blackmail is the name of her new book
she according to Whitney Webb the ca has
been doing sex trafficking entrapment on
people since the 30s like they did it to
uh the head of the CIA what was or the
FBI what's that guy's name for 40 years
he he was found like you know doing some
sex acts on a guy they found him took
some pictures and uh yeah Kennedy they
had stuff on I mean and Kennedy wouldn't
play a ball according to Whitney Webb No
I just I highly recommend watching this
Jimmy Dore episode with Whitney Webb I
was gonna say why wouldn't they right if
we know the FBI is getting involved in
like the Whitmer stuff it's like getting
a bunch of getting like what do they
have like 14 agents and like two guys
and then convince them to go for a ride
along and stuff if they're going to
Stage fake Terror plots why wouldn't
they also try to Blackmail people yeah I
mean the FBI has been doing it since its
Inception especially under Edgar Hoover
and everything he was doing and Ian the
CIA was started in 1947 not in the 30s
but the CIA was also doing a lot of
crazy things like dosing people with
acid and and LSD and not telling them
that they were dosing them and running
larger human experiments uh MK Ultra uh
us Operation Paperclip there's so many
Sinister things that the intelligence
agencies have been doing throughout the
last few decades to think that they're
not doing it now when they were never
held accountable for it before is
absolutely naive and crazy I don't know
what do you think your line of work
because you see a lot of the stuff on
the front line you're seeing a lot of
this uh you know kind of larger
engineering by the intelligence agencies
on social media that promote a lot of
this nonsense
yeah I think that the specifically with
the Twitter files that that really
brought this out a lot it was really
interesting where they're so embedded
with big Tech which basically is
policing our speech
it's just it's just so it's just so
insane that that that they're able to
have that much power over random
citizens I mean there's so much and then
the way that they were going after you
know moms at school burn meetings and
and all that kind of stuff it's they
they're they're just they've been gone
unchecked for a decade and they probably
censored you yeah probably I mean I was
part of the Twitter files I I didn't see
anything specific with the FBI but I'm I
would not be surprised if that comes out
not yet let's let's jump to the story
from the hill and then we'll start
getting into all that stuff we have this
uh the hill story DeSantis
Administration launches investigation
into holiday drag show then there's a I
I'm not sure if I have pulled it up but
Geraldo Rivera was like what why are
they going after drag performances it's
like yo this guy doesn't read the news
and that's the challenge I'm not mad at
Geraldo I mean you can be mad at him you
criticize them for a lot of things but
the only store he he sees gets filtered
for the mainstream media and they say
does Santa's Target's drag show what
they don't say in the headline is that
the drag show had children there and
they were explicitly warned by the
Florida government not to have children
at the event when they found out kids
were at a drag show with sexualized
performances the decent it was a I don't
know if it was a sentence explicitly but
it's the dbpr was like okay we're going
to be investigating this because we told
you not to have kids there it's illegal
they say the Florida Department of
Business and Professional Regulation on
Wednesday announced it was investigating
a holiday-themed drag show in South
Florida
they said it was sexually explicit and
marketed to Children the department is
actively investigating the matter
including video footage and photographs
from the in from the event
the statement said the department plans
to share any evidence collected into
investigation with the State Department
of Law Enforcement and criminal
liability look I'm surprised it's taking
this long to deal with this stuff and
it's like the best we get right now this
is Florida of all places where they had
an all ages drag show where there's
videos of children there and it is it
like there there's men humping each
other on stage there's there's a um
sexual organs displayed secondary sexual
organs this on display for people to
look at and little kids I post a lot
about drag shows and I'll just say this
was one of the worst ones I've ever seen
I was talking to James Lindsay when we
were at TP USA and I was like look
this was before we went on stage and we
brought up a gun stage and I was like
first it was drag queen Story Hour and
they kept saying it's just reading a
book calm down my response was drag is a
sexualized performance if you took a
stripper a go-go dancer wearing their
outfit before they take it off and have
them read for kids go go dancer Story
Hour would that be appropriate oh that's
totally different I was totally
different I'm like same thing the Go-Go
dancer's not naked but that makes no
sense why would you do it then they
started doing all ages drag shows it's
just dancing calm down they're just just
dancing then we saw that one where it
said it's not going to lick itself on
the wall they're talking about ice cream
you're paranoid now they have simulated
sodomy and overt sex acts in front of
children they also have strippers by the
men in front of kids well there's a few
videos of that I mean when where is this
gonna end Dragon stripping is not the
same it's not but they'll do both for
kids and then money being shoved down
People's Clothing which is also like
what are you doing like I think it's
clear explicit grooming yeah so this is
exactly this is about son James Lindsay
I'm like it hits it hits grooming on the
head like it's the nail on the head with
a hammer it starts with all we're doing
is reading books introducing the concept
in the most innocent of ways so you can
plausible deniability just reading books
then you start dancing while you read
the books we're just dancing then you
eventually get into the full drag
performance it's it's fine it's just
it's a fashion show then you get into
the heart of what it truly is is meant
to be for these people and it's
sexualized sodomy Etc and now they're in
it full swing that was the point that
was The Grooming and it worked they
weren't just grooming kids they were
grooming the parents to thinking it was
okay to bring their they're grooming the
media too yeah by the way no they admit
that themselves at the point of drag is
to queer kids they admit that yeah James
Lindsay posts this study yeah the paper
they actually wrote it themselves saying
the goal is to put glitter in a carpet
that can never be removed to get it in
the brains of these children they they
admit their grooming but they need
people you know in these these activists
in the media to lie to cover it up yeah
and they'll happily go along when you
said this was the worst uh drag show so
far that you've seen was that just
graphically like nature sexual sexually
yes Graphics did you see the footage of
it I don't think so there was like there
was someone on there with massive
massive fake breasts totally exposed we
can't show it they were saying no you'll
get the video will go men you know
thrusting into each other and things
like that the kids were there yeah I
can't show it on YouTube kids were there
okay kids were being interviewed kids
were putting were put on the stage and
on camera they were asked talked to well
so so there's one part where one of the
drag performers is talking about overt
sex acts that they engage in there's
children sitting right in front then
there then they ask the child what's
your favorite part of the event this was
in Texas and the kid's like nothing it's
like these parents are bringing these
kids there yeah because the parents were
groomed and legally speaking if a parent
takes a kid to a over 18 movie they're
allowed right with a parent I'm asking
generally with parental Guardian are
they allowed to see porn or kid no 13
year old nope the parents then convicted
of something if they expose 13 year old
to it not porn I don't know the exact
law we've had people mention enticement
of a minor or there's exploitation laws
about inter like if you go up to a child
as an adult even your child and start
showing them graphic images
depending on the context right if you if
if a parent brings a book on the birds
and the bees and to be even a book like
genderqueer it No One's Gonna arrest a
parent for being like I want to show you
a book and explain these things to you I
think you're ready but if a parent goes
to a kid and shows them overt like
pornographic hardcore stuff that's when
you're getting to the line Child
Services yeah kids get being forced to
watch that stuff yeah and if an adult
who's uh here's here here's the like
look there's a challenge I think most
people might agree with when a parent
decides it's time to talk to their kids
about the birds and the bees and in what
form that will be
I don't think the form of that is
showing your kids hardcore porn
obviously but there may be some people
who argue well you know these kids are
going to experience these things on the
internet and they got to be warned about
it it's like okay finding that line I'll
admit is it's going to be difficult for
the law to figure out I think we as
moral human beings like in this room and
people watching can clearly say you know
when you see it don't show it to kids
but for the law to figure out it's going
to be a lot harder
now the problem here is these are
strangers if a parent brought their kid
to a strip club they're going to get
arrested and charged they're endangering
a child period hands down the issue is
it's cultural
a cop seeing a kid at a strip club is
going to be like this parent brought a
kid to a strip club the bar is in
trouble eight the 21 and up the parents
in trouble but because it's drag it's
under that protected flag so the cops
are going I'm such a pathetic scared
piece of garbage I won't actually do
anything so these cops are just standing
back and saying nothing I think that's
the problem is that drag is like if I
came in here where's wearing a dress
tonight I'd be in drag there's no
sexuality I mean you could argue that
there's but you can do that asexually
but when they start to take off clothing
even a a sleeve or simulating taking off
clothing then it become stripping or
stripping each other like rabbit dogs
that's blatant or sex you know zipping a
fake unzipping down no no no no
unzipping a fake female organ to birth
something on stage in front of children
any kind of unzipping I would argue with
strip that's what they were that's what
they did so stripping is different than
drag and if you're showing kids sniping
that's another conversation in no the
same thing well you can wear a dress and
not strip yes but drag performances this
is what the left has been our lizard for
instance the left has been claiming that
drag it's not stripping they're taking
their clothes off on stage for a custom
change and it's like that's tripping
yeah if you're taking your clothes off
it's interesting they're just playing
semantics to manipulate to groom and
DeSantis is saying Eddie Izzard he was
famous comedian still is that uh would
wear women's clothing he dressed and
drag for his comedy shows but he's just
straight up a dude no he's a guy no he's
full you're right Eddie Izard Eddie
Izzard is full on trans right now oh
really yeah yeah Eddie Izard for like 20
years was just a dude that would wear
makeup and a dress and do comedy so if a
kid saw that I don't think there's
anything immoral about it it's just
Eddie expressing himself well this isn't
the only uh story that DeSantis Eddie
Izzard is gender fluid using the word
transgender uh
I don't know yep trans woman Eddie
izzard's been out as trans for a while
now I wonder what the next psyop's going
to be against the governor of Florida
since just a couple months ago we had
the whole don't say gay bill that the
whole country was talking about that all
the celebrities were talking about that
literally just allowed kindergarters to
have parental consent when talking about
these topics and again they they lied
about it they're probably going to be
lying about this they're going to
probably run another psyop about this
and it's interesting seeing Ron DeSantis
at the head of a lot of these
controversies he also knows that this is
this is important that this is a bigger
cultural war and he also was involved in
local school races he also made sure
that Local School Board elections uh had
a lot of his support and uh things are
definitely changing in Florida but I I
do see him as as one of the major uh
kind of uh people that will be attacked
in 2023 I don't know what do you think
no for sure I mean he's definitely at
the Forefront of all these issues it's
incredible to watch I wish more people
would look at him and take cues from him
you know other governors
um but there is I wanted to mention that
other video I don't know if you remember
it there was a viral video of a stripper
walking down I guess the stage holding a
little child's hand so that was in
Florida and they actually lost their
liquor license wow yeah like DeSantis is
really taking these things seriously oh
that's great he's not and now we have
this in Florida too so I think you know
I think it's a matter of time until we
see
um something something happened where
this is not gonna be a lot in Florida
anymore we are opening a venue as I
mentioned uh several times now and we
actually second guessed whether or not I
was going to do it one of the reasons
was to put it simply the economy is
going to implode in a catastrophic
collapse in the next 60 to 90 days so
people have told me but uh when we're
looking at buying this property you know
we're hearing bad things but there was
another issue not too far away was a
venue that had an all ages drag show for
Halloween or something like that and
then I was just like
I don't know if I want to open a
business in an area that's doing
something like that next to a venue that
would allow that and then I thought
about it and I was like
this is West Virginia
I think if we
are to open this venue it would insulate
this area to prevent things like this
because if any one of these venues tries
to do something like that again
we will just hold our own event and
invite everyone down to come hang out
and then be like we're in a peacefully
have our voices be heard by hanging out
having coffee doing our own event and
and putting pressure on the city to not
allow all ages shows uh sex shows just
not going to happen we need that
presence to stop it retreating wouldn't
make sense we have to push back right
well I'll just say if if you're looking
for a place where there's no drag shows
it's going to be basically impossible to
find
it's in everything I don't care about
drag shows for kids I'm saying for
characters for kids yeah yeah shout out
to Jack Huger of The Young Turks who
said if he had the money he'd put on the
biggest drag show ever and the first
thing I thought was like what do you
mean if you had the money like dude's a
millionaire it's What's it gonna cost to
put on a big drag show you know you can
get a 3 000 seater venue your total cost
is going to be like 30 to 40 Grand I
know it's a lot of money but not for The
Young Turks their Network they can't
afford that okay fine I said we'll do it
this is gonna be awesome Tim Cass is
going to sponsor one of the coolest drag
shows ever there's going to be you know
it's a free admission it's going to be
funny there will be comedy there will be
an epic performance free food free booze
of course with booze of course it's 21
and over only but uh it'll be great no
and everyone's like yeah okay great yeah
you're an adult go do what you want
right
disappear to all of a sudden they're
just like not interested what's how
about just open a strip club be old
school be old school about it I don't
know but like I don't care about drag
shows I actually think they are nobody
cares about drag shows till they started
involving kids yeah and I I don't think
anybody still cares about drag shows
it's just the kids the kids yeah and
then they they say I think Jack was like
you know they don't really care because
they don't care about Hooters and I'm
like yo I don't like Hooters
what's wrong with voters
exploitative women I don't know my
opinion making them wear tight outfits
of women with big boobs free marketing
trying to sell food women women choose
to work they're allowed to work there I
don't think it's appropriate place for
kids to go eat strip clubs exist some of
them have food don't care go to a strip
club if you want to go strip club I
don't I'm not it's not my thing full
disclosure I like the buffalo wings at
Hooters of course you do I always liked
them I've only had them I never believed
that well have you had them yes good
buffalo sauce you didn't think so oh
absolutely not this is like 2006 or five
like my whole life when I'm younger I'm
hearing from all my dude friends like
well no we should go to I mean the wings
are actually really good at Hooters and
I'm like it's a sauce I'm like is that
for real or are they just saying that
because I want to see boobs and then
like I go with them and I'm like yo
These Wings suck like I've never I'm
like thanks thanks a lot of my wings I I
it felt very weird
I just don't think it's right for kids I
don't like children beauty pageants yeah
those are yeah they're always like oh
call a beauty pen just yeah sure where
I'm against that too yeah a child's not
appropriate for kids yeah
but I will say this too bringing some
young boys to a restaurant where you're
upset that women wear clothing dude if
the kids went to the beach they would
see more boobs than they would see at
Hooters I'm not going to demand Hooters
be shut down because the women have have
low cut tops women have boobs boys will
see them whether that Hooters or at the
beach or walking around hey be inclusive
here uh Bill Gates has moved men could
have moves too my point is he got the
vegan moves two and I'll put it this way
here's my hierarchy of like how bad it
is Hooters yeah you shouldn't bring kids
to a place called Hooters where the
intent is that the the the waitresses
have big tits hanging out but little
boys are going to see big tits walking
down the street so I'm not crying about
it then you've got child beauty pageants
okay these are little girls like 10
years old covered in makeup and wearing
dresses and being told to shake their
hips I'm like that's you no I don't I
don't like that at all that I would say
not a fan of probably shouldn't be doing
that then you get to the the Florida
style or the Texas style drag shows
we've seen where men are thrusting into
each other singing a song about
screwdolph banging dudes and it's like
children should definitely not be there
and that should be a crime I think
calling it a drag show is is a
disservice to the movement because it's
a sex show at that point yes wait
there's a there's another level on top
of that which kids themselves are the
drag queens so we're talking about Minor
yeah like the NBC News had that uh Good
Morning America had uh you know a young
child children stripping for money at a
gay bar where men threw money at the
little boy taking Justin wasn't that
guy's name Desmond Desmond Desmond that
was the first I saw at 2015 or something
is that right and then there are so many
now didn't they do like a TV show about
drag games or something yeah it's like
okay yeah that's grooming dude was
talking about taking he's talking about
doing ketamine too yeah snorting it like
didn't he like do a bumper like a
simulated dude like people were saying
how does that little that 10 year old
kid know how to simulate doing drugs up
the nose snorting drugs
I I think it's like end of the Republic
like
nastiness that comes out when the
society is so you know so wealthy and so
opulent that it doesn't know what else
to do but what in investigating it what
have you seen as like Solutions or
countermeasures too I don't know teach
children other things maybe more moral
or that align more with your morals well
number one is don't send your kids to
public school so yeah that's that's all
I can say
um I think that that will help a lot and
I know it's really difficult a lot of
people it's their only option
um I'm really fortunate I never I I went
to private school and I feel really
grateful
um but I think that I think the root
cause of a lot of the problems we're
seeing now is public schools I agree and
I want to add to that point Ian
I was in uh Chicago Dundee Dundee
Illinois
went to a bar uh over the holidays and
there were slot machines along the back
wall and that surprised me in West
Virginia there's slot machines
everywhere you go into any bar they got
slot machines they have places they call
hot spots you walk in it's it's
literally just a room with slot machines
and it's kind of sad I'm seeing these
people who are afflicted by an opioid
crisis in West Virginia the shutting
down of their industry coal mining and
things like that so what do they do they
take their government check every month
every week and they show up and they sit
in front of a slot machine and just
press the button over and over again to
trigger that dopamine and that's that
that to me reminds me of that rat
experiment where they put the thing on
the rat's brain that when the rat would
press the button it would release
dopamine that's all it is when they go
to these slot machines but to see this
in Illinois I was like whoa because
Illinois I grew up there was always like
you can't gamble super hard to do
illegal it was only legal to have a
casino if the casino was on a Riverboat
so they have like in in harrahs and
Joliet is built on water so it's legally
allowed even though it's like it's fixed
it's not really a boat but like you know
the laws then they have rivers and stuff
so there are casinos there but to now
see a regular old bar putting in a
casino putting in a slot machine
I'm just thinking like this is the end
of the Republic people have nothing left
to strive for there is no Community
there is no dopamine hit released in
someone's brain when they help their
fellow man they want to sit in front of
a machine and press the button until
they get that interested in the same
doctors and the same psychologist that
helped engineer these these people to
gamble and to to sit there and to give
all of their money or their government
check it to that that casino are the
same scientists the same doctors that
have engineered social media that have
engineered the algorithms to keep people
hooked on there and I don't know about
you but but for me personally I I do see
the the biggest groomer out there is the
algorithm is Tick Tock is what people
are being shown on on Facebook on on
YouTube but they're being recommended
what they're being conditioned and mind
controlled to believed with their
perception of reality being shaped by
these algorithms that literally uh do
make them dependent on those little
dopamine hits that incentivize a lot of
this larger debauchery and degenerate
Behavior do you think that's true or no
yeah and to add to that I I think it was
Tucker Carlson show they did a segment
and they basically investigated the
Chinese algorithm for tick tock versus
the American algorithm and it was
nothing to compare Math and Science the
yeah literally they're teach they're
they're the Chinese one is educational
and you can learn all different kinds of
interesting things and the American one
they're teaching them about pronouns and
gender identity and
and all that kind of garbage and booty
shaking yeah but I will give a shout out
to the Instagram algorithm which has
been super weird because I don't know
why
but it just started showing me Billiards
videos and it actually improved my game
oh I'm excited I don't know what I'm
doing I play pool for fun and then also
I learned how to Rack a proper eight
ball game I learned like proper English
I'm not good at it or anything but I was
like oh is that how you do it I'm like I
had an idea so I'm like I'm sitting
there like I'm a toilet I'm on Instagram
and I'm scrolling and then all of a
sudden it shows some dude doing a curve
shot and I was like oh I didn't know you
could do that and then I'm playing and
I'm like I'm actually playing better now
like tips and tricks randomly and
algorithmically making me better at pool
don't know why I don't know maybe it's
my name yeah yeah they know what to they
know yeah yeah they kind of works there
too but they know how to hook you in I'm
not a pool player here's the click yeah
but they know it's gonna make you watch
right they know it's going to make you
interact with it and pay attention to it
it hears the clicking of the balls in
the Green Room when you're playing on
your phone and it's tracking it's like a
couple games a week when we're hanging
out and like we'll come downstairs we
have a pool top of your last name dude
yeah right it probably is my last name
but you know that it recommend but
here's what it does
they have that auto scroll feature you
can swipe up and it will show you random
videos Tick Tock is similar
and then what happens is it'll show you
a random video here here's here's here's
the reality there's golf videos I swipe
right past them it doesn't show me golf
videos it tried to and I ignored the
video when the billiards video popped up
I saw that and I watched the whole thing
and then it was like this guy wants to
learn more about how to play pool I see
that on Ice Girl Tech talk a lot and I
see that a lot if I spend an extra like
three seconds on a video that I don't
want to see a random video then my whole
feed is just going to be that type of
video yeah and it's real it takes it
actually takes a few days or weeks to
get out of that algorithm and get back
to your regular it's super annoying too
I mean and and this is true for
Instagram where I'll see a video and it
like the the the thumbnail like the the
graphic they use for the overlay is
misleading so I'll actually watch it and
then not knowing what it is I'll watch a
lot of it and go oh no and then you
refresh your feed and it's nothing but
garbage fake videos and I'm like just
show me Jordan Clark doing triple flares
on his scooter again that's why I see
that video all the time I think his
name's Jordan and R Willie I love that
Nitro Circus stuff so uh what Jordan
Clark he landed the triple flare
recently right that was a big deal uh I
think so basically it's a triple
backflip 180 and it was like one of the
coolest things my Instagram is nothing
but skateboarding blading scooting and
BMX stuff but you get these videos and
then all of a sudden they start
dominating your feed I have to actively
go in and I'll start scrolling through
and looking for skateboarding and then
watching it letting it play so it resets
the algorithm yeah what happens to these
kids left or right they start seeing
political content and they get sucked
into it yeah and instead of playing pool
and learning how to play pool better
people are learning how to be a victim
in society or how to be the next craze
or the next Trend in society that's
going to be popular and get them more
likes I I think there's a lot more to
this algorithm than we actually let on
especially since you know there's larger
psychological studies talking about how
they could control people's emotions and
if they could control emotions they can
control a human being very effectively
Facebook did this to oh 10 plus years
ago I remember talking about it uh
whenever they were doing the studies on
unsuspecting users but how do you see
this do you think people are just
naturally the way they are in social
media highlights this or do you think
social media is shaping individuals to
do this
um what do you think is it the egg or
the chicken that came first definitely
social media is shaping people I think
weren't there studies or some some con
some something came out about Tick Tock
and their algorithm I think and I I
think Tick Tock is probably the worst
when it comes to all these social media
platforms I would say because not just
is not just are they shaping people
first of all tick tock targets youth so
we're talking about young people in
America not just our they shaping them
but it's the type of content that
they're doing it with it's all of this
gender identity stuff and and all of
this really making children insecure
with their identity and it's really
dangerous I'll tell you I watch
pornography from time to time you porn
shout out uh
why would you do market research Luke no
it's not but well I tell you I see trans
videos pop up every once in a while and
I never saw that before it's very
disconcerting to see a trans person
having sex when you think there's it's a
straight couple CIS couple and then he's
got a large this is a slur yeah those
are flares you should say we learn my
language I guess to assimilate with
modern culture but I mean that's another
algorithm like what's that teaching
people it's vulnerable people too
it's not just that it's it's I I
wouldn't say it's specifically trans
when it comes to the porn stuff it's any
of the weird insane stuff that's causing
kids to face to have distress there was
like there were some studies that and
look I'll put this way you know we
started the segment talking about
gambling as a sign of the fall of the
Republic porn absolutely is in my
opinion too now look I'm I'm fairly
libertarian I don't care you you guys
can watch whatever you want to watch do
whatever you want to do live your life
I'm not a conservative a lot of
conservatives don't feel that way and
don't agree that's that's fine that's
the you know by all means but I will be
the first to say outright there there
were studies showing that young men were
becoming they were having erectile
dysfunction with their significant
others because their brains were being
rewired by watching not like well I
don't the right word is like fantasy
porn and and impossible circumstance
porn where like 12 women are swing on
ceiling fans and it's like orchestrated
in this ridiculous way that's not
possible for the average person so you
get these young men who are developing
fetishes watching the stuff that then
can't be satisfied by just being with
their girlfriends and it was resulting
in ed
so this stuff I agree low birth rates so
maybe when you add all these things
together when it starts to feel like a
big conspiracy right because you've got
the castration of kids the abortion of
kids you've got people advocating for
reducing population growth on TED Talk
stages and then you've got young men
having their brains Twisted by Insane
porn free everywhere all over the
Internet with Tick Tock you're like an
expert I would imagine at this point is
it like it's owned by bite dance as far
as I know I don't think this has changed
which is basically subservient to the
CCP as are all Chinese companies at this
stage of Earth
um what do you know like when you're in
there do you feel the algorithm pushing
you and twisting you
first area no in the what
into well I searched certain things so
I'm actively seeking out the videos
about about gender and those teachers
grooming kids and a lot of the the
anti-white racism stuff so I'm actually
seeking that out but they're sometimes
I'll scroll through it and I'm like how
do they know this video is exactly what
I'm looking for they they feed me
exactly what I want and then you're like
I'm just gonna repost it on Twitter and
then they're like you're and then
they're writing businesses on me they
call me a terrorist you're like hey guys
someone made this video look you're
inciting violence against them by
sharing exactly what they said yeah no
I'm a little literal terrorist they call
me do you ever feel like you gaze into
the abyss for so long that you become
the demon
no that's like a niche I I I understand
the point like if you're trying to make
it even long enough but like trying to
expose it if it becomes you higher being
like hey they're grooming kids I don't
think in any way has become that much I
guess a more gentle way to ask the
question is do you ever feel like dirty
like just remembering the things you've
seen does it ever it gets really really
dark sometimes yeah I can imagine it's
it's really tough It's I spend a lot of
hours looking through all the stuff it's
really dark it's really depressing but
it's so important so you know I kind of
pushed myself but there are definitely
times that I'm like I can't I can't look
at this anymore how did you start doing
this how did you start doing this so it
was during coved
um
I started noticing all these crazy
bizarre videos they were going they were
going viral
um and I was like this stuff is so crazy
I need to show more people this and I
just started posting it to Twitter and
that's really how I started there was no
plan there was no you know there I
wasn't I didn't make a business plan I
wasn't I didn't make a plan for how to
go get famous and go viral it just sort
of happened
yeah I remember like Libs I remember
when your account started getting bigger
and then I would be like I need to
follow this like this this is like an
excellent source like exposing a lot of
this what people are doing in their own
words I think it's I think it's a really
good
um it's I think more people should learn
from it and I have seen others accounts
sort of pop up and try to do it too
which I think is really good it's such a
it's such a good way to expose them it's
the best way actually do you work with
anyone else or did you start it yourself
or do you start it yourself and now do
you work I started myself and now I work
with others so sort of around the time
when I was done by Taytay we could go to
that soon
um so Seth Dillon from The Babylon me he
is incredible one of the most incredible
people I've ever met and worked with he
stepped up and uh basically offered to
help me made this my career so now it's
full time
and shout out to Seth I hope he's
watching this he's really such a great
person he's always so supportive from
the beginning always by my side always
offering to help and in all of you know
there's a lot of ups and downs in this
and he was always always there for me so
thank you Seth what does that mean he
helped helped you make it your career
because the rumor was that he bought
Libs of tick tock I I'm I don't feel
comfortable going into all the specifics
um but he yeah he basically we partnered
up
yeah well there you go yeah he's amazing
that is awesome he's been on the show
before yeah I love that guy yeah cool is
it like less work like less less
strenuous work but more fulfilling work
now do you find it's still it's still
strenuous it's
it's sometimes it's really hard there
are days when I'm like I need to take a
break I can't I can't look at this stuff
anymore and then I'll just take a day
off I haven't I haven't really taken a
vacation in a year and a half since I've
done I've taken off a day here and there
um but it's so it's just some when I
whenever I feel like you know am I even
doing anything or I'm feeling down about
the account or or the content or or you
know maybe
thinking any of those sort of things I'm
like I feel like I have a moral
obligation to continue when you see
what's out there and you see how bad it
really is I'm like how can I ever think
about stopping I can't this is too
important I completely get it I agree
you know at a certain point especially
with the company we're running I was
talking to someone recently and uh well
maybe it was Sheamus and I was
explaining like with the threats with
the swatting with all of the just as
crazy as things are he was like this is
why a lot of people would they expect
most people to just sell out Take the
Money and Run yeah you know it's like oh
you've made a bunch of money quick shut
it all down and hide but it's it's it's
I guess for me and for a lot of people
doing shows like this talking about it
was never about making money right it
was about like wow this is messed up I
gotta like I gotta talk about it you
know we gotta we gotta tell people hey
this is a bad thing yeah also I think
the higher the risk the higher the
reward so the more they come after you I
think that also
I I think that actually ends up helping
in the long run I think Ben Shapiro's a
good example right it's it's not like I
don't want to come out and say that
being harassed threatened and attacked
is a good thing for anybody but so long
as you're willing to stand up people get
your back and then with all of that
negativity like when he was at DePaul
trying to speak and the cops told him
they'd arrest them those kind of moments
get more attention and help you in your
cause by shining a light on what's
Happening the injustices I mean in my
case when I was dogs I doubled my
followers literally within 24 hours yeah
we got a Times Square billboard yeah
thank you for that thank you shout out
to the Daily wire everybody give
everybody some reference with what
happened you were I can tell the story
or you can I mean from what I saw was
you were just posting content at some
point Taylor Lorenz a journalist with
shout out to what's up Tay I do love you
as a human just so you know man um well
she's not hanging out with you because
she claims to be immunocompromised and
she was all alone on New Year's Eve you
know just you're gonna be you're okay I
mean look like I I want to talk about
that I want to talk about the whole
doxing thing and explain how that
happened and that story the long story
short just to give everybody a primer
Taylor Lorenz it was she was with the
Washington Post at the time right she
still is yeah yeah but she's bouncing
around she's like the Atlantic New York
Times published a link to an address
associated with you then they quickly
removed it and then denied having done
it like outright lied like never did it
and there were Archives of it so I put
out a tweet like they're denying it it's
crazy like we know it happened do I need
to put up a Times Square billboard
saying lit you know Taylor Lorenz docks
Libs of tick tock and then Jeremy boring
of the daily wire said I'm down and so I
hit him up we talked and he was like bro
we can we can help make all this happen
the daily wire crew basically organized
all of it and we got a billboard in
Times Square apparently she was freaking
out that's what that's what I heard but
what I want to say real quick before we
get into all that
Taylor Lorenz posted a few days before
New Year's that it was like Loki the
greatest of all time to stay home on New
Year's because we're also exhausted then
posted on New Year's how awful it was
for people to be posting these party
selfies when ERS are being overloaded
and right there you could see exactly
what's going on with this with this
Taylor Lorenz this Tate I feel I felt so
bad for her because you know you know on
New Year's
I'm with my girlfriend I'm with Luke
Luke's you know we got a bunch of uh my
brothers there
and we're standing there in Times Square
at a party and the ball drop happens and
I get to kiss my girlfriend we're
surrounded by people with free food and
drinks and we're all laughing and like
amazing and then I see her tweets and
she's like it's good to be home alone
with no friends I can't believe people
are posting videos and I was like damn
I feel so bad for her I did kind of feel
bad too is she lashing out this way
because she's just lonely and desperate
that's what I would think yes so anyway
I just wanted to point that out before
we get into it but she she docks you so
let's let's break that down what
happened how did that how did that go
down that's also the biggest demographic
for the uh Democratic voting Base by the
way single single women older women
sorry go ahead yeah well we don't know
exactly how old she is
between 38 and 43 okay yeah so she she I
believe she's 30. she was born in 1984
but her whole thing is that she pretends
to be really young and
she yeah and then you know interviews 16
year olds and stuff like that and really
weird but so like let's talk about how
she docks you
so when did it happen April 19th
um so I had like two two to three days
notice
um she was harassing me calling me
endlessly texting me emailing me anyone
who shared my last name so I I knew that
this was gonna happen I quickly went to
um a friend's home in the middle of
nowhere just in case anything happened I
was scared to be home
um and
yeah and then she she published my name
with an address
um
I mean it took me like a few days I was
kind of like just running on adrenaline
and then a few days later I it like hit
me what happened and
yeah I mean what specific questions do
you have well no I guess like the story
of like what happened when it all went
down what was the result of that like
what what kind of yeah so so look look
they published a story with a direct
link to a link and they also referenced
another website where they didn't link
it so it was two where people can go and
find another address and then removed
the link shortly after and then lied
saying they never did right but we never
did that nope and I'm like there's an
archive showing you did no no no no what
was your experience immediately after
like in the 20 minutes after the post
went up did you start to have personal
experiences like people contact you and
stuff yeah oh my God my my phone was
blowing up like crazy it was probably
the most insane week of my life so far I
mean I'm pretty young but so far
um what I was gonna say it wasn't just
the address though it was your name my
name right now all of a sudden everybody
knew that this account which had people
were threat like they want they wanted
to find out who you were because as
there were death threats and then she
facilitated the extremists who were
trying to find out who you were she
facilitated like for them I think yeah
that yeah that definitely but
immediately following it I think this
the thing that was the top of mind for
me was was what comes next right okay so
now everyone has my name my location so
what's gonna happen now are people going
to show up are there or is someone going
to come try to murder me or hurt me so
it was that unknown of what's gonna
happen and then the other thing keep in
mind is that no one knew what I looked
like there so that was the other thing
I'm like how long will it take for them
to find a picture and I waited that was
actually the most
it was actually it was really insecure
feeling because every day I'm like is
today going to be the day that they
found that they released a picture they
find something or they show up to my
house and stalk me or I don't know and I
waited a week I waited two weeks I
waited a month two months it's been
eight months they never found a picture
yet and I mean now obviously I chose to
to reveal myself but
um that was it was every single time I
left my house I'm like is someone here
are they coming it's just the unknown so
I think that was that's what they want
right so when and and that's part of the
reason why I took that away from them by
showing myself I got that power away
from them when the Club Q thing happened
I said how do we stop the violence but
also stop these grooming events they
went nuts over this and I I people
calling my phone we got a ton of death
threats and they were explicitly saying
they want to make sure that people like
me you Matt Walsh and a few other people
like Andy know cannot live comfortably
and without Feeling Extreme they
outright say that yeah I know and it's
funny because I'm like dude like I
tweeted could you imagine some like
antifa soy boy showing up to the
mountains of West Virginia into Maga
country and then like breaking into a
house I'll tell you what happened uh
they got shot at and I don't want that
to happen it's scares me that one of our
guys you know opened fire and that
happened please do not come like don't
break into a property in West Virginia
For the Love of All That is Holy the
people in West Virginia
this is West Virginia man we're not
talking about we're not talking about
New Jersey we're not talking about New
York New York you're breaking the person
says please don't hurt me West Virginia
you you break through the window and
there's a right-wing nut job with it
with a Barrett M82 aimed right at you
and he's yelling yeeha like the people
out here shooting their backyards for
fun so when people were doxing my
address
somehow
you know some people that's not my
address that's not where I live don't go
there someone's going to shoot you this
is insane one of the properties that we
have one it's my house I was not there
because we take precautions we set
things up I can't say too much because
it's security but we do these things not
too dissimilar to what Elon Musk does
with his plane to make sure it's hard to
find where I'm at someone thought they
found us some things happened I can't
say for security reasons but lead us to
believe it was political
then I think it was it was three guys
but two guys had broken in there's a
third guy who I don't think was in the
house and
let's say shots were fired
and then they Dove out the window these
are the report that we got there's a
bullet hole I took a picture of it I
post I posted it they they think that by
doing these things and threatening us
I'm going to live in fear look I don't
know where you live I'm just gonna say
this
yeah I'm in West Virginia and I'm not
scared I'm scared for them I'm scared
for them please don't come here I will
not hesitate to use for us if I if
someone comes to hurt me so I'll get
that out there too regarding I'm scared
because the people who live in in the
mountains out here
like these are the every house is a
trump flag on it every house is an fjb
ever ever look there are some like DC
liberal people who want to get out of
the big city and they come out here and
everyone just rolls their eyes at them
but we're talking about Farmland we're
talking about big big signs that people
make on their own saying like Trump
trump even to Santas I'm like antifa
comes out here someone's gonna make a
phone call and be like everybody
everybody come quick antifa's showing up
and then everyone's on their porch with
their guns like don't don't don't mess
around yeah I just I don't want people
to get hurt I strongly believe and I've
been saying this for months if they
would have the opportunity to kill us
me and you some you know many other
people with knowing that they're not
gonna face any consequences they would
absolutely do it they would absolutely
take the shot I think they tried to with
Andy no
when they attack the reason that they
didn't come to First yeah is first of
all we have security but secondly
because they don't want to go to prison
most people right I don't think prison's
the issue these are collectivists they
they have powerful organizational
apparati or whatever whatever the word
is that will get them out organizations
will pay the bail we'll fight for them
the issue I think is truly opportunity
and the political ramifications these
activists know so let's let's talk about
Andy no Andy Noe is covering a protest
in Portland and they mercilessly beat
him leaving his his mouth bleeding his
ears bleeding it I believe they truly
wanted to kill him but it has to be a
random strike from a bunch of different
people
because if one person shows up with a
gun like Michael reinel did it is
condemned outright even the attack on
Andy know led to widespread political
Commendation even CNN briefly said it
was wrong that's a problem for political
ideologue collectivists who are trying
to win favor so they want to but it has
to be done in a way that doesn't hurt
their cause Michael reinel shot Aaron
Danielson twice in the chest and it was
bad for them that that's too it's it's
too much what they need is a false flag
what what James Lindsay's been calling a
drag Floyd uh like they what they need
is for them to be the victim and them to
be attacked that's why I keep telling
people violence doesn't work they're
trying to trick you into using it
because then law enforcement can respond
with justification under under the
banner of Law and regular people will be
scared and sight against you regarding
like because I I think I think really
the goal of these of of activists is to
get you to stop whatever that means and
so regarding psychological warfare which
is basically what's been happening with
doxing and all that how do you react
when you feel that someone is
implementing psychological warfare on
you I completely ignore it I'll I'll
literally just tune it out and it takes
a it takes a lot of work to get to that
place where you could really do that but
I was telling Tucker on the show like I
it's totally just noise I completely
tune it out and I sleep really well at
night you got to do it you have to and I
think everyone with a big following and
and sort of prominence finds their own
strategy that works for them you
probably have your strategy for when
they really yeah
I always talk about there was there's
like they just make things up yeah
literally one of my favorite pizza box
thing like they'll just make stuff up
they claim someone actually posted on
Twitter that I showed up to their house
in Boston at 2AM and turned their TV on
while their friends and family were
sleeping and it woke everybody up and
and they're like wow I can't believe he
did so crazy that sounds just like
something he would do and I'm like did
no one find the story odd like they
didn't call some strange mans in my home
turn my TV on but people just need to
make things up and I believe it someone
posted on Twitter that so so Taylor
wrote an article that I used to be a
real estate agent in Brooklyn which is
true since I saw someone wrote on
Twitter that they remember working with
me once and I stole their clients from
them because I told their clients that
they shouldn't work with him because
he's gay and I hate gay people
that's what they said and obviously that
never happened completely made up I have
no idea what he's talking about but the
bigger aspect here to really consider
it's not just crazy people there's a lot
of crazy people out there but but these
are also powerful State institutions
that are going along with a lot of this
larger ideology of punishing people
censoring them de-platforming them uh
going out and and asking social media
companies to delete them because of the
ideas that they detest a lot of this for
me personally brings a lot of ethos of
Mao zedong's cultural revolution there's
a lot of things that happen then that I
think are very close to happening here I
don't think we're there yet but I think
we're definitely on a trajectory of
going there but this to me is just uh
you know very unsafe very insane and it
feels like we're down a path down to
Total political partisanship that
there's no going back from there's
nothing that could even bring us back
together where we could be one cohesive
Nation one cohesive people it feels like
this is the divide and conquer agenda
and the state has a particular victim
and it has a particular Victor already
picked out let me let me I gotta pull up
this story because of what Luke just
said this is from the Texan
Texas Supreme Court denies Jeff
younger's petition to keep children in
Texas in light of California trans
Refuge law
this one's this is big
this is the guy who divorces his wife
he has a son the wife says the sun is
trans and wants to be a girl and the dad
says that's not true the mom is just
saying that
there are other Witnesses who have
claimed that the kid wants to be a
little boy acts like a little boy but
whenever the mom comes around the kid
just does whatever the mom tells the kid
to do the mom is going to bring the kid
to California the dad sued saying
California has a non-extradition law I
think it just went into effect right now
right on the first
that says that if they chemically
castrate the law doesn't say chemically
castrated says gender
but if they provide gender affirming
medical surgeries or treatment to a
child they cannot be extradited by
another state who criminally charges
them so my question here is with all
this going on
I want you guys
you guys watching comment Super Chat
what do you think happens
when a child is taken from one state to
another state
Texas says it's illegal to do these
surgeries California says it's a it's a
it's illegal for the police to assist in
the extradition of a Doctor Who does
these surgeries what's going to happen
if this man's son is chemically
castrated and Texas says we're filing
criminal charges and California says
haha we don't care
not just we don't care but come here to
stay safe come and take him is what
they're going to say so the question I
have is
we are dealing with an extreme moral
issue a man's son I understand it's a
woman's son as well but the woman is the
one who took the kid if the man took the
kid and fled I would say a woman's child
is being taken from her a man's son is
being taken from him
and they are saying they will chemically
or potentially surgically castrate his
son
look
what scares me here is Texas will do
nothing California will smile the
federal government will threaten to
arrest him and Target his family but
what does a man do when his child is
taken away from him and they say they're
going to sterilize castrate
neuter whatever
like I think we're heading towards
really dangerous dangerous territory
Jeff needs a voice I think if you guys
are into it we should have him on the
show I don't know if the invitations
ever been offered but I think before
that thing would happen at surgery or
some sort of happened to his child
against his will I would like to let him
speak out against it so people
understand what he's going through
I that's like I don't you have kids you
talk about that yeah I think about
I don't even have kids and I and I I'm
defensive about them like it's what what
a man do to protect his child
that's what that's that that this is
what I was talking about two scenarios
for a potential Civil War breakout and
Texas was was one was was the example in
both scenarios
a man and a woman are in a relationship
woman gets pregnant eight months later
she says you know what I've been talking
to my girlfriends I don't like this guy
I'm gonna break it off but this Baby's
bad news because it means we're in a
relationship for the rest for for 18
years at minimum and then we're always
going to see each other because of this
kid
I know I'll go to Colorado get an
abortion Texas says you can't do it you
can't abort a kid at eight months
Colorado says you can
is it kidnapping if the woman who's
eight months pregnant the baby is viable
goes to Colorado to have it terminated
what happened what happens if the father
says you know that that's that that baby
is viable she's gonna kill it please
stop them what happens
now that's that's a scenario where it's
kind of tough because there is a
distinction between a baby that's born
and a baby not born even if the baby has
was conceived at the exact same moment a
baby at eight months who is then
delivered prematurely and alive and the
woman kidnaps that baby and rushes to
Colorado that's kidnapping an attempted
murder and all that stuff but if the
baby's still in the womb the woman has a
right to literally destroy the babies by
kill it
then the other scenario is this
California's Sanctuary law for for
chemical castration and surgical genital
mutilation surgeries
what happens when Texas says that's
illegal you can't do it and the parent
kidnaps the child bringing them out of
state and then has the child castrated
is Texas going to send Troopers to
California no is the federal government
no
my fear then is that a posse will form
and you're going to see skirmishes and
militia action because I got to tell you
it's one thing when we argue about
antifa versus The Proud boys and there's
some nebulous ideological goal where a
guy is like America and other guys like
America is bad now we're gonna fight
yeah sure it's another thing when a guy
is like my son was taken from me I've
seen those Harrison Ford movies give me
back my son you know some dude's gonna
lose it and he's and his buddies are
going to go with them and they are going
to go kick doors in they should go to
the Supreme Court I would think the
federal government's supposed to step in
when there's cross state issues and then
this is definitely a Supreme Court case
in my opinion it went to the Texas
Supreme Court right and yeah and they
said no they voted in favor of the
mother he said he wanted to stop him
from going to California because then
she will get the she will basically
Texas ruled both parents have to sign
off on on you know this this surgery or
medical transition
so then the wife is like I'm gonna go to
California
and then he's like no don't let her do
it and they're like no she can and he's
like but if she goes she's gonna get the
kid the surgery
and they're like whatever does the mama
have soul custody is that no but 50.
yeah but once so I I think yeah the way
it worked is that the court said both
parents have equal say but I don't know
exactly who has uh custody doesn't
necessarily mean how much time you get
with the kid so I don't know about that
the point is the moment she's in
California
Texas law is irrelevant to her and so is
this guy just going to be like oh woe is
me I lost myself this is like federal
law what is it federally can you
federally legally
get your kid castrated that's nuts I
mean like remember that story from
Loudoun County the his the guy his kid
was raped yep and no one was listening
to him all of his complaints were going
on deaf ears and so he showed up to the
schoolroom meeting and finally made a
fuss and then he got arrested there yep
they dragged him out so they dragged him
out that that famous uh video it's
definitely cult as the school was
covering up multiple and then we find
out assaults the physical assaults on on
you know children it's absolutely
certainly I want to clarify for you Ian
sorry guys uh in August 20 21 a Dallas
District Court granted his ex-wife full
custody but on October 2021 court order
agreed to by both parents states that
neither parent May treat a child with
hormonal suppression therapy Purity
blockers and or transgender reassignment
if and uh surgery if any without the
consent of the parents or court order
but California Senate Bill prohibits the
enforcement of an order based on another
State's law authorizing a child to be
removed from their parent based on that
parent or Guardian allowing a child to
receive gender affirming health care so
she's using her full custody to go under
the radar out of the state where she's
going to go where bypass this Texas law
and of course the left perspective is
this poor child the mother saving it
this is why I think it's cultural
Solutions like um hearing his voice like
you need tens and hundreds of thousands
of people wretching in horror at what
could happen to a small child because of
what and this is not the first time it
happened this happened in Canada as well
where a father was punished or even
talking to the media about a situation
where the state came in and said we're
going to transition your child he said
and a mother said we're going to
transition our child and he said no he
was arrested because he's spoken about
this it's crazy I made a tweet I said
how do you think humans would react to
finding out that not only are we not
alone in the universe but that we're
effectively livestock for an alien
species how would humans react to that
maybe the reason aliens haven't revealed
themselves to humans because humans are
more reasoning than say chickens so
that's what I was thinking about we got
chickens
we take the roosters out because the
roosters cause problems in chicken
Society roosters battle for dominance
and then get to bang all the chickens
and then they they pair up in in certain
numbers like one rooster will have like
six hens one will have eight but you
gotta have a good amount of hens for
each rooster otherwise they fight too
much but to the chickens this is normal
life we don't like their normal life I
don't like the roosters fighting no
human does so we remove one of the
roosters if they're a problem and they
won't stop playing by the rules and
right now Roberto Jr is king of that
chicken City with like 30 ladies we as
the people controlling the animals
dictate there's also
um what's it called like a capon or
something like that you can take the
rooster if you want for meat and you can
castrate it and then you get basically
chicken meat you know rooster meat's
tough you got to pressure cook it but if
you is that what it's called something
like that capons or chickens testicles
yes yeah so you take the rooster that
you cut open its back where it's it's
their inside and you remove them or you
whatever so I'm thinking about this and
it's like the state coming into someone
and saying we're taking your kids and
we're going to surgically alter them is
exactly like what we do to goats when
they tie the rubber band around the nuts
so they eventually fall off like we own
them they're livestock
now I don't think this is actually
anything to do with aliens it's that the
governments and the elites are treating
us like chickens like livestock did it
to Saddam Hussein I mean if they want
something and I don't know who they are
exactly but when people that are
attempting to control her yeah someone's
I think there's groups of people that
are trying to Vie for power they will
just you know go out you gotta wonder
when you have people going up on stage
at a TED Talk saying there's too many
people on this planet and we have to
reduce population growth what kind of
thing would they be willing to do if
they really believe this you guys saw
that Paul was Nam Ehrlich
the population bomb guy who keeps saying
there's too many people and then it
never turns out to be true yeah Jane
Goodall was just talking about it too
said all these problems would be avoided
if we had the population that we had 500
years ago which is just a bland generic
statement probably not totally accurate
yo indicating 500 million people about I
mean there is there is some truth to you
will own nothing and you will be happy
in that if you don't know you can't
regret not having it right like I can't
teleport I don't wake up crying that I
can't teleport I never could
I there are airplanes you can you can
buy a ticket day of get on a plane and
fly somewhere when when the when the
flights get canceled we get angry about
it you know so it's like if it so when
when I was flying for the holidays and
the playing gets canceled
I was just like dude I'm not gonna
scream and cry over like a busted plane
because the giant metal skybird someone
else like all of humanity is working
towards building like can't service me
in a single day where it's a luxury I
get it
but the idea of these Elites is that
take these things away from people
take away their knowledge of these
things and they won't be unhappy yeah
they're trying I'm thinking about that
with eating cockroaches and stuff the
bug narrative like if we ate meat
growing up so we know like if I had
grown up eating cockroaches fried and my
mom watching my mom do it I wouldn't
even think twice about eating
cockroaches and that we're the
generation where they're trying to
change I hate saying they it's so
generic but where you know economic
foreign
I'm just imagining these people
are chickens themselves thinking
everyone else are chickens and that
they're smarter chickens than the other
chickens I'm like dude you don't know
what you're talking about you think you
do you're wrong science changes what
Elon Musk talks about this we need more
people and he's right think about man
think about anything
there's a can of STEEZ over there I have
green tea I see Lucas drinking the can
was made by a canning company the the
printer ink or whatever is put onto the
can is made by a different company the
drink itself is made by a different
company it it takes such a tremendous
amount of specialty to make a single
item in this like let alone a phone I
mean the Plastics the metals the glass
all of the different specialties
requires experts in all of these
different fields
if the population of the planet dropped
to 500 million you would lose things
like you'd lose Plastics Cobalt you were
going to get your electrical vehicle
batteries oh no bro an electric car
couldn't exist on a population of 500
million people on this planet yeah I
just don't see it as being possible
electric cars are such complex machines
maybe some rudimentary kind of thing you
know you can get a handful of people but
who's going to mine the copper who's
going to then fashion the electric
motors who's going to generate the
energy all of the the more people we
have on the planet or I should say in
existence because we can leave the
Planet Too the more Specialties there
are the more we can do things to put it
very simply
when we talk about inventions and the
crazy things we have a levitating UFOs
in here right in front of Ian all that
really happens is some dude goes I
figured out how to how to make a thing
that will create magnetism if you put
electric current through it then someone
else goes hey I can buy those from you
and then put an axle in it and it'll
spin that axle and drive a wheel the
electric motor company is different from
the car company so basically what's
happening is tons of people are making
things that on their own are pointless
and then other people are connecting
things and making them do other things
less people means less technology I'll
put it much more simply
the Roman Empire had indoor plumbing
after the fall of the Roman Empire they
just didn't have it anymore so in in
Europe and After the Dark Ages they
would just take dumps in Holes in the
Floor that would flop to the ground or
they would chuck them out the window in
buckets a thousand years after that's a
thousand years after they had indoor
plumbing in Rome A Thousand Years Later
they're like just forgot how to do it
yeah now imagine and that's not even
less people that's more people now
imagine what was in the Library of
Alexandria
um
again I I do I do believe that there was
kind of more advanced civilizations that
we don't know about but I think history
is just as fake as our news today and we
have to realize that the stories were
being told are being told for a very
specific reason a lot of the people that
are in charge a lot of them are
eugenicists a lot of them are
narcissists a lot of them are Control
Freaks and they're trying to get control
of every aspect of your life and we have
to remember the freedoms that we give up
today our grandchildren will never know
of tomorrow I forgot who said that
someone else a lot smarter than me
actually said that but we're living in a
world where our freedoms are slowly and
surely just being taken away Technology
Innovation is is creeping into our
society and it's slowly eviscerating any
kind of anonymity any kind of privacy
any kind of uh secrecy that we
previously had before is gone we have
satellites we have cell phones we have
we have cameras we have facial
recognition watching everyone one of our
moves tracking our purchases tracking
where we're going tracking when we're
taking a dump we're truly moving towards
a society that is absolutely controlled
by these population control freaks and I
I think we're at a crossing point
especially right now I think right now
we're at a very crucial turning point in
the world history especially when it
comes to the larger experiment that is
the United States and its larger
freedoms and it could either go total
freedom total slavery
um and I think that decision is going to
be made very soon I think it's going to
be made in 2023 to be honest with you
guys it's important to remember that
right now is all there is that time is
something humans made up to get places
at the same moment but it's always right
now and we are changing this right now
reality constantly so let that be some
motivation to get up there and move baby
that's my analysis what do you think
what's your analysis and assessment of
where we are as a society and where
we're moving forward
um I think culturally I'm really scared
for what's coming next just based on the
stuff that I've had to
to see uh through running running levels
of sex talk
um so yeah I mean
I mean I don't know I think
I I think that I would rather I'd rather
all the technology we have and live now
with all that even with all the
the the bad parts that comes with it
then to have lived hundreds of years ago
without what we have now
um so yeah I think we just have to be
more vigilant
with our online security
um
and yeah whenever whenever they talk
about eating the bugs I literally go on
a buy steak I'm like
I'm never gonna eat the bugs and I'm
just gonna eat steak hard but they're
implementing it in places like Australia
where a thousand schools are now forcing
their children uh to to eat the bugs
inside of major school areas really I
didn't see that story and and you know
they're they're also forcing people to
take medical procedures uh that some
people are connecting to some people
just you know dropping Dead uh suddenly
there's a story right now happening uh
right now within the NFL that also I
think is going to be worth talking about
potentially on the after show since
there's been a lot of uh coincidences
that have been happening you see this
story I guess it just just happened I'm
reading I'm reading the chat room and
people in the chat room are talking yeah
Demar Hamlin collapsed on the field in a
game uh the game was suspended so first
the dude was tackled
he doesn't hit his head or anything he
gets tackled and takes the fall to his
left shoulder stands up slowly starts he
walks around for a few seconds then just
Falls right back they started doing CPR
and giving him oxygen and I guess
they're suspending the game
I don't know what happened
um you loaded into an ambulance people
were crying and they're suspending the
game
yo I there I've seen injuries in
football games before I've not heard of
maybe I'm not a big football guy of
people crying
and then the game being suspended did
the dude die
from being tackled like that that's what
some people are saying in the in the
chat room I mean let me just let me just
show you the video it's not your
favorite people the people in the chat
room are saying that he did pass away
here take a look at this video did this
just happen yeah this just happened so
so all right I'm so down all right
this guy right here yeah this guy right
here this is DeMar so there here you go
he gets tackled
he's right here let me play it for you
boom goes down onto his left shoulder
stands right up yeah
didn't hit his head or nothing and then
gone
he hit his head going down he's wearing
a helmet look at that
yeah it doesn't look bad it did not look
bad at all I've I've fallen so much
worse skating I was told by a doctor
recently that if you are to get a
coveted vaccine or a booster that you
should take like six weeks off well he
told me that I or so he was telling
someone I think I was watching a show to
take six weeks what does that have to do
with the football game to take six weeks
off of strenuous labor I don't know if
he has been vaccinated or yeah it could
be totally irrelevant I don't know but
for someone if they're not getting that
instruction and they're getting like
medical procedures or injections or
things like that and then they're just
going full hard moving I mean that can
be a toll on your cardio well Dr Peter
McCullough has uh and um another doctor
have different explanations to it and
and scientific understanding of it
that's being questioned right now uh
Twitter is finally allowing us to have a
platform or a lot of this science is
actually being debated in an honest and
open real way as we recently found out
through through the Twitter files that
of course the White House was
manipulating scientific data scientists
and the actual information because it
was in convenient for them and their
larger political agenda these are the
factory files that are supposed to be
coming out no no these are the Twitter
files that were released and now the
faucy files are going to right I'm
saying then the next step of this we we
are we already know from Twitter files
that got released that because of covet
specifically the government was
intervening getting people to spend like
Alex Berenson was a very big story but
the fauci files are going to
supposedly directly implicate fauci
himself
no
no way no even when we control the house
yeah of course are you kidding oh man
sorry like Kevin McCarthy he's making
all these promises Marjorie Taylor
Green's backing him they they probably
cut some kind of deal so she'd get back
on committees if she supported them
there are people who are saying when it
comes to Kevin McCarthy as Speaker
take what you can get my response is
nope I'm not doing it I don't care I
don't like Republicans I don't like the
Republican party I never did Donald
Trump was something different I didn't
even like Trump in 2016. but then I saw
what he was doing I liked at least what
we got out of polling troops out of the
Middle East getting our getting our
troops out of Syria all that nonsense no
war in Ukraine for instance the economy
was doing pretty well and I was like all
right I'll take it like there's a
Libertarian element that was able to
piggyback Freedom caucus people people
like DeSantis off of what Trump was
doing I like that I'll take it but now I
don't know what Trump's doing but I'm
not I'm not interested I mean it's it's
really stupid
the things he's put up on Truth social
and stuff whatever I still think he's
way better than anyone in the Republican
state Republican establishment but the
idea that I like someone who never liked
the Republican party is gonna in any way
get behind someone like Kevin McCarthy
is never gonna happen like do the dude
could be sitting here right in front of
me I'm gonna be like I don't care like
yeah
McCarthy called for Trump to be
impeached to be kicked out of office
Michael let me see yeah keep keep
talking but with this for Michael malice
on January 3rd 2019 Democrats officially
retook the house and elected Nancy
Pelosi a speaker the Republicans
nominated Kevin McCarthy as their
candidate the person who gave the
nominating speech was Liz Cheney yeah
I'm not interested in any of that so
guys if you're a republican Marjorie
Taylor green you're cheering for
McCarthy hey man do your thing Democrats
cheer for Nancy Pelosi they do their
thing fine whatever I don't care
libertarian all the way I'm not I'm not
gonna get behind Kevin McCarthy you guys
down with the mises caucus I like those
guys yeah I like them a lot from uh from
one to a hundred and a hundred is Ron
Paul and one is Liz Cheney where do you
say see yourself on that political
Spectrum
I mean I'll just say that give me a
number give me a number
um
100 total freedom uh Ron Paul
one
one Liz Cheney I'm explaining it no
Freedom total status neocon neocon is no
one 100 is Ron Paul where are you on
that Spectrum I'll say like
75. okay what do you like interesting
he's 100 I'm 100. he's Ron Paul I'm so
glad you're here I'm 80. come on I was
even critical of like Ron Paul when Ron
Paul was running so I'm critical of
everybody Ron total freedom Paul
yeah like I don't want to I don't want
to say 100 because it's too absolute but
I don't want to be even one degree
closer to Liz Cheney yeah I mean well
that's technically where you are so let
me know in the comments section where do
you stand in the comment section 100 to
one let me know your number um I love
the chat room you guys are awesome and
it's great being a part of these
conversations 99.5
a lot of 16 a lot of 69s like uh are you
sorry no you said you said you uh that
Trump would be you know Trump is the
best one so are you Trump or DeSantis
well I don't know if Trump is the best
one I mean it's your friend the
Republican party uh he's better than the
establishment Republicans DeSantis is I
think at this point I don't even know
what Trump's doing I'd say DeSantis over
Trump yeah in in like February and April
I was saying I don't know DeSantis is
he's got the tact he's younger but uh I
don't know if he has the aggression
you know Trump look at the way he's
taking on all of the wokeness in Florida
I know I mean I'm not Advocate I'm not
what about you Trump or December I'm not
answering that oh come on here's the
thing is that and I did an interview the
other day and they tried they tried
getting me to give an answer and I don't
owe allegiance to any political tiny
politician they work for us I'll watch
the Santa's campaign I'll watch Trump
campaign and then I'll make a decision
yeah true though you think you'll be a
republican for sure do you just kind of
go with whoever no we're probably count
all the way for sure have you always
been Republican yeah so what do you
think about McCarthy as a speaker
uh
not fun
I mean
I wish there were other options
um I don't think he'd be my first choice
but I think that just the fact that we
have that it will be a republican
speaker is always is going to be good
regardless
um but no he would not be my first
choice what do you think he wouldn't be
my eighth Choice he wouldn't be my it
wouldn't be my 100 this is what we have
so we have to work with it I think I
yeah I I get that but I don't have to
work with it no we you know you don't
but my my view is
look I didn't vote for Trump against
Hillary despite knowing that Hillary
Clinton is evil and Trump was just crazy
like I don't mean crazy like insane I
mean he was like yes
more chaotic is probably the way I would
describe it he was more chaotic he was
more arrogant and these things I didn't
think he had the decorum and that's just
me I understand people thought his
attitude is exactly what the White House
needed then I saw what he was doing and
I was like okay yeah this this deserves
a second term like this is good stuff
it's not it's not perfect or anything so
I don't I don't like the lesser of two
evils vote when it came to Biden versus
Trump I was like Trump did things I
really liked he set timetables for
getting out of the Middle East he got us
out of Syria he did those things there's
a lot of complicated stuff there but the
North Korea peace deals Abraham Accords
all these things I thought were very
good and then I look at Joe Biden and
I'm like he's crooked as they come this
is a no-brainer you know he also can't
get a sentence out I mean he's not
dementia so but now looking at what the
Republican establishment has always had
to offer there's a reason why I've never
voted for them until now because they're
a garbage party yeah and like the funny
thing is when you look at the polling
Democrats mostly like Democrats Democrat
voters mostly like Democrat politicians
Republican voters don't even like
Republican politicians I think
Republicans tend to be people who know
politics but are begrudgingly voting for
the best thing they can get and I'm kind
of like well you know do your thing like
you know I like Marjory Taylor green a
lot and she's supporting Kevin McCarthy
and I'm like oh you know you know go for
it you know by all means like that
that's your thing I'm not a part of the
Republican party I don't like Mitch
McConnell Lindsey Graham or Kevin
McCarthy fee I'm not going to support
that if they win or if McCarthy wins I
don't I I see very little difference
between him and Nancy Pelosi I I get it
Pelosi is very very bad but on my
establishment establishment
establishment like I don't know like
when Donald Trump gets elected in 2016
from 2017 until 2019 the established
Republicans worked against him
establishment Republicans were the ones
who helped change the voting rules to
make sure he lost there's no way I'm
getting behind someone like Kevin
McCarthy it's just not gonna happen and
then Matt Gates I think is saying Jim
Jordan and I'm like I didn't care about
that like Matt Gates maybe Donald Trump
for speakers sure I don't even know who
I would support but it's not going to be
any of these guys knock it matters I'm
not in Congress I'm not gonna be voting
anyway so if Kevin look I get it if
Kevin McCarthy wins it's better than
Nancy Pelosi but part of me really wants
to see him lose because it would be the
funniest thing ever after this
apocalyptic performance in the midterms
relative to what people wanted to be
Rana McDaniel still getting support
after all these failures I think they
need to lose I think Republicans need to
lose the speakership when they have the
majority just because of how how
functional they are well look
there's a coalition of of moderate
individuals who are voting Republican
right now because of the stuff you know
for instance you you highlight
but I'm not going to get behind Kevin
McCarthy because the creepos are doing
weird children sex shows or anything
like that like you you are not getting
me to vote Republican because of the
culture War if you if I'm concerned
about these issues I like DeSantis the
Santos is actually effective so someone
like him as Speaker I'm like I I like it
he is surrounding himself with
establishment people though so we'll see
I don't want to ramble too long we got
to go to super chants but maybe we'll
talk a little bit more so we're going to
go to super chats if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and become a member at
timcast.com we're going to have a
members only uncensored show coming up
and we're going to talk more about some
very serious issues related to like the
death penalty and things like that
things that are pretty dark but uh don't
just become a member for for just that
when you become a member you're helping
our mission
we've got we bought a building the
building is done we own it we are going
to be putting a cafe hang out on the
first floor we're gonna be putting up
TVs that will play shows of ours we're
going to play people like Viva fry we're
gonna play like ricada if they're if
they're cool with us playing their
videos on the TVs in the in the venue
the idea is someone comes in for a cup
of coffee and what do they see on the TV
screens not Fox News not CNN they see
content you know and love from people we
know and love and respect people like
Crowder for instance and I want to have
a hundred of these in a couple years I
want to have 10 000 of these in the next
five ten years I know ambitious but then
think about regular people walking in to
buy a coffee they know the brand they
see the shows it creates a physical
location where people can can be hanging
out sharing ideas I think that's a huge
component of what we have to do plus
we're doing other shows and a bunch of
other things we got a skate show coming
soon I'm really excited for this we're
gonna we're gonna read the super chats
let's go
smash that like button and uh let's see
what do we got
j marie says history shows us over and
over unchecked power leads to tyranny
what happened to Libs of tick tock is
just one example and history is filled
with them Gulag archipelago says it all
stay safe
thank you yeah
well how long till till you think we're
on the gulag together hanging out
at this point
it's a couple months well the gulag was
actually the government uh Department
that created the prisons the prisons
themselves weren't gulags so you're
saying we'll be running yes when we're
in the gulag it means we're running them
cool I'll see a lot of my followers
there probably mimic says I guarantee
Taylor Lorenz has hate watching the crap
out of this episode feverishly taking
notes to completely misrepresent and lie
about yeah we talked about that before
the show I know what that's like they're
gonna take whatever you say and I know I
already know what they're gonna take I
can't wait I know it's now I kind of can
empathize like when you're alone and
like how you start to try to Mother
Society like when I look outside for
Solutions because I'm so you know I
don't even realize how miserable I am
because I'm so miserable like it's like
it's cognitive dissonance I can't even
sense it because it's so horrible kind
of thing I hope she's not going someone
but it seems like it someone said
franchise for our coffee shops yes
that's a really good idea so one thing
we can do is once we set up a couple of
them create a franchise plan and like
stipulations and like you know the
general contract and then uh help people
set up their own shops I think I like
the Chick-fil-A model
one one company one person can only own
one location to guarantee quality and
stuff like that yeah yeah I think
they're really really cool we do the
Saturday morning cartoons events at all
the locations of stipulation Saturday
morning from like six to eight you know
there's approved shows that we can play
probably like well maybe we'll just do
the daily wire stuff chip chill or
whatever they're putting out Rex
Friedman
what for kids no I'm talking about
Saturday morning families can come hang
out there's no drag shows there no yeah
we wouldn't allow that and so that would
be part of like franchise contracts you
can't have you know these kinds of
things so you run like the same
syndicated stuff across all franchise
yeah like like Jimmy John's franchises
are required to put up signs you know we
would have stuff like that like you know
as a part of this business you recognize
Saturday morning community events people
can come in like Chick-fil-As are closed
on Sundays things like that but we'll
see you know depending it depends on
what we can do and then uh we're gonna
start selling our coffee very soon I'm
so excited dude yeah just steamed
perfect temperature not burnt crisp the
rise with Roberto Jr breakfast to blend
we gotta get a bunch of coconut Waters
that we can add for them if they want it
sweetened well you buy your own peanut
butter powder in there I don't know do
that themselves yeah but uh one of our
products is rise with Roberto Jr
I like it yeah when is your first
location opening you have a date or no
no no but we're gonna start selling the
coffee online we we actually have been
working on this for a little bit so the
coffee designs are all ready and we
actually have sampled them already I'm
really excited the I think the rise of
the Birdo junior is really good I'm not
a light roast I like dark roast so we're
doing a very dark roast I love it and
it's coming soon it's coming soon cool
all right Kent Pittsburgh says I'm lost
prevention for a big box store and wore
my Roberto stand your ground shirt for
the first time yesterday and caught two
shoplifters within two hours Roberto
sends shivers down the spine of
criminals that's right he does
stand your ground it's Roberto Jr
actually
I love it Roberto's retired to cocktown
and then people were because Roberto Jr
is in charge of chicken City now and
they're like he's he sits on the throne
he did not build
Roberto did all the work so we got two
more Generations until they've
completely forget how they got here
that's right that's how it works for
General so we're going to start uh I
think right now actually we're gonna
start incubating some new some new
chickens and then we'll have to retire
some you know retires and eat them
because they taste really good
fried especially all right let's go
let's go what do we got
pup Shepard says if our money is spread
between many podcasts can we buy a
single episode on timcast rather than
subscribe Hi Ian Wags Wags that's a very
very very good idea I'll look into how
we can do that I'm not sure but it could
be like you know three bucks for like
a couple episodes to watch or something
I don't know maybe it's like 2.99 to
watch on episode or 10 bucks a month for
unlimited access if someone asks if you
could do five bucks a month to get like
a day later get all the behind the
scenes comment 24 hours later than the
10 a month one someone just sent me a
message and asked that it's it's the
challenge is it's just techno like yeah
that's what I first thought building
that stuff out right it's a lot of money
to build and then it's just
it's like 10 bucks a month gives you
everything and I'm actually I'm looking
at what we have and it's like we're
actually pretty cheap I think the daily
wire is 13 bucks I was shocked to find
you know Luke uncensored was like 15
bucks it's definitely worth uh every
penny there's a lot of things you get
three master classes exclusive
merchandise and t-shirts at Cost where
it's cheap and a forum where I have to
answer all of your questions in an AMA
to meet other members so I've been
working really hard on my members area
and uh we've been censored so many times
this is the answer this is the way to do
it Luke unsetzer.com I gotta I gotta
read this one you might I don't know if
you're gonna like it real Hydro you know
you'll love him he says Libs of tick
tock looks like Taylor Lorenz it's
amazing I guess you become what you hate
Tim's still not listening to people
I I had to bring it up because people
mentioned it when you went on Tucker
they were like you you don't you don't
you're not like identical anything but
they're like you're kind of similar
looking I don't see it at all but she
wrote it was she wrote something on
Twitter like you know about it's so
misogynistic she's like oh two white
women with long dark hair and she wrote
this listen to what she wrote she wrote
one is a one is a hate account which
says gay people shouldn't exist and one
is an investigative journalist but she
didn't specify which one is which well
you're the investigative journalist I
know so that's what I wrote on Twitter
I was like Taylor breaking Taylor comes
out as homophobic you know well I don't
know I think it's funny that people are
pointing it out you should just she's
like the you know the ear the evil
mirror version you know she's not though
there's nothing similar well I mean like
I'm saying not that you're not that
you're similar but she's the she's the
mirror opposite it's an inversion you
know you do investigative reporting by
actually showing videos and exposing it
and it's very it's very light to be
honest it's like hey look at what this
person said whereas what she does is she
fabricates things you know yeah there
you go I mean she's watching right now
yeah she's all alone in her 90 degree
apartment I'd love to see you guys do a
show like even I don't know how long I
offer to do a live stream with her
that'd be great and she didn't respond
just if a call like the distance
man especially now things are getting
drastic we got to come together well
maybe if Taylor's watching this my offer
still stands until 12 p.m tonight look I
always I always give a shout out to Joey
salads because he he did that I don't
know if you know who you know Joey
salads no he's a big YouTuber and he was
making he made prank videos and stuff
like that and he made these videos where
it's like one was he left a car in a in
a in a in a parking lot and put a bunch
of trump stickers on it Trump signs or
whatever and he's like I'm gonna wait
and see what happens and we're gonna put
a hidden camera and the next thing you
see is a bunch of black dudes are
smashing the car and destroying it turns
out though he staged the whole thing
some dude filmed it happened called him
out Persona non-grad everyone was like F
this guy and then I remember he hit me
up and I was going to Sweden and I was
like dude F you I know what you did blah
blah he got mad I thought about it and I
was like if this guy is getting crapped
on because he did something wrong and
his only opportunity is to
be pushed away he will accept that
so if I say you know what man he said he
was sorry I accept your apology I'll go
talk to him give him an opportunity to
actually come back into the fold don't
push people away when they're remorseful
and they regret what they did even if
they regret it for the wrong reasons
maybe he one day was like I really
shouldn't have done that he said he got
carried away he didn't even think about
what he was he was doing maybe maybe he
really was evil whatever one of people
whoever people want to say about him
if you got a guy and he has the option
to go the dark path or the light path
and you're standing on the light path
and you're saying get the F away from me
you go down that dark path why would you
do that why wouldn't you be like I
accept your apology come with us to the
light side and do good and help people
and now he does silly pranks with his
girlfriend he's like so I think the
right thing to do is for someone like
you know even Taylor lorenzis you're
always welcome to hang out have a beer
you know and and stop doing this really
nasty evil stuff and being just a bad
person and uh you know at any point
Taylor ends wants to be like I'm not
going to do this stuff anymore I just
want to be friends and play Monopoly you
can come and play Monopoly like we'll
hang out with you no one's gonna be mad
at you we'll laugh we'll play pool we'll
get sushi and everyone will be like
thank you for doing the right thing
you're always welcome to be friends with
us but if you guys make trades in
Monopoly that are screwing me over I'm
gonna flip the board I'm just kidding
I'll play it out it's the luck of the
dice
like that's a thing there's a reason why
people like Hassan Taylor Jank all these
people won't come on shows like this
there's a reason why Ben Shapiro is
willing to interview anybody but they're
not willing to come to the other side
it's because they know what they're
doing is wrong it's because they know
that they're lying it's because they
know that they're exploiting ignorant
individuals who don't follow politics
and they know Taylor Lorenz knows that
if she actually sits down with you she
would be proven wrong about everything
she's ever said and so she can't yeah
they need to maintain that that Veil
that lie I don't think we can keep going
on like that as a species
well
um I'd say no
but you know we gotta we gotta we gotta
the fail will be lifted one way or
another whether we do it by choice or by
chips getting pushed into our brains
we're just dying people are really
starting to see through all the lies so
and no one takes her seriously
I I think she's on the verge of being
fired yeah I I think so too I'm
surprised she hasn't been yet she must
have something on them I oh a contract I
have sources yeah so this may come as a
surprise to people but I used to work in
in corporate press I have sources and
they tell me that there are people at
the Washington Post who are veterans who
are losing their minds and it's causing
real problems internally these are
people like who have been there for a
decade plus who genuinely wanted to be
heroic journalists and are now watching
this vapid you know Taylor Lorenz do
Tick-Tock social media gossip and it's
not news there are people that wanted to
be like I have exposed the CEO of major
corporation trafficking children like
here's the expose journalism yeah
instead The Washington Post invests in
someone complaining about Mean Tweets
and that becomes their Center the focus
and so I heard that it was causing kind
of instability
but uh uh higher-ups are extremely angry
at the decision the idea was and this
could be this could be nonsense this is
just from people I know who work in New
York media they're saying that the
reason the decision to hire her was
because they felt that the media
landscape was changing and that she
represented what younger people were
more interested in and that's why she
was so controversial and that the
controversy was good because that's what
generates traffic these days that's
where it goes wrong that's right
controversy for clicks is not the way
forward and I know I know some veteran
journalists who've done reporting in
like Bolivia and Colombia cartel uh
Nicaragua like government conflicts you
know like I know some journalists who
have gone down and um like the fart
groups I think that's Colombia they've
done some really heavy stuff and they're
just like it is the most demoralizing
thing in the world to risk your life and
then be told we're going to lead with
the person said a nasty word to one of
our reporters on Twitter yeah and
they're just like if you want to be a a
rag be a rag I want to do journalism and
it's it's you know they got to make the
decision speaking of Rogan did an
interview with the guy who went to the
Cobalt mines in the Congo exposed like
tens of thousands of humans just digging
Cobalt with their bare hands and little
you guys gotta watch that it's not cold
that is real journalism right there that
guy risked his freaking life and is
still risking his life in the life of
his co-workers doing that let's read
some more we got Matthew Schneider says
Tim Cass should make a fictional series
about government agencies involved
conspiracies and subterfuge then call it
the f-files we were talking about this
my brother had the idea make like movies
where so we we're kind of bouncing ideas
back and forth one of the ideas we had
was it's Hillary Clinton and she has uh
uh a couple things maybe we should say
this I'll just say it anyway she has a
she has a a viewing device I can see the
future
and they keep seeing the rise of new
Hitlers these people who become
prominent and then end up leading
fascist factions and so you know she has
no choice but to stop all of these
people I'll say this one the more detail
because I think people understand the
general idea well and the other was that
uh she runs a suicide prevention
non-profit we'll we'll I'll save that
joke for uh afterwards but anyway the
idea is uh you know make make funny
short films you know poking fun at a
bunch of conspiracy theories if you get
my drift who knows where Seth Rich would
have ended up you know he could have
been a a very uh
Cult of Personality a leader you know
let's read some more Super chats oh
we'll we'll we'll I'll give you more
details on the members only it was funny
we have one about lizard people and
stuff like that I think it's one
all right all right what do we got
delimar says to put this in movie land
our R rated is under 17 with adult nc17
is no one under 17 period x is adult NC
17 was made due to extreme violence
however not sexually explicit since
x-rated existed the laws are all there
there you go if it's x-rated you can't
have kids no matter what or NC-17 yep
okay yeah what was there a movie
recently that was nc17 I don't know yeah
they were pretty rare yeah our rate it
is you you can bring a kid in If the
parents with them and then PG-13 was if
your third if the kid's 13 they can go
that's so weird but on the internet you
could get anything you want yeah that's
that's messed up man
internet is is bad for kids you know
what I'm saying
all right H music says I've lived in the
Chicago suburbs my entire life slot
machines especially video poker machines
have been legal and in places for years
Bennigan's on Michigan Avenue had a
video poker machine 25 years ago I
didn't know that and I don't remember
seeing those things and what I was told
is that there was a recent compromise
with the ability to put slot machines in
within the past few years due to some
law expiring Bars were getting mad about
whether or not they could attract
patrons and they made a compromise
saying okay how about we give you slot
machines and so you know
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Ah your last
name cast
nope pool
Jason says Tim you need to play a game
of snooker
I've seen the game played but I don't
know what it is called snooker it's like
yeah it's like a British version of pool
snook is such a funny word and then
there's uh was it called Karem Billiards
or something like that yeah where it's
like there's no pockets the goal is to
hit both balls in one turn or something
like that you get a point if you do that
sounds like fun too you just play it on
a regular pool table you know what I
like I like um
uh bumper pool that's fun yeah the table
with the little bumpers on it
all right Daniel damasik says Tate did a
five-hour podcast with Patrick Bet David
worth a listen time frame of interview
was shortly after his cancellation and
debanking interesting
yeah there's some infotainment podcast
is that what it was that's a Patrick's
uh show I don't know you might have more
shows now I think he's branching out
they have an entire network now
yeah
what do we got
Alex P says check DMS from the Patriot
pen maker hold on let me I gotta correct
that last one it's valutainment not
infotainment yeah value team the value
table podcast
Courts are there not to provide justice
courts are to provide good men with a
reason not to use violence in pursuit of
Justice the left is removing that
well it's not just the courts the courts
have limited enforcement capabilities
it's that
law enforcement is supposed to adhere to
the court rulings
the crazy thing about the Supreme Court
we're talking with Will Chamberlain and
he said the Supreme Court is scared that
if they push too hard on certain rulings
it will expose them as having no real
power
the Supreme Court can say whatever they
want but who's to say anyone will abide
by it
geez so if they enfor if they enact
certain rulings that are too different
from the culture people will just ignore
their rulings and once they do the
confidence and the rulings are shattered
I think it's funny when people they were
wearing those shirts that abort the
Supreme Court and it's just like I get
it you don't like the law it's just so
it's what throughout the courts because
you don't like the it's just what do you
expect if that's the sentiment then we
really are just seeing the dismantling
of this country
all right ghost Crusader says Tim it was
Mel Gibson that screams give me back my
son Harrison Ford screamed get off my
plane it was um Family Guy I think where
they had Harrison Ford running down the
street grabbing people and saying
something about like what where I want
my son back do you want can you Google
that or whatever Harrison Ford Family
Guy give me back my son
that was the reference get me back my
son
who is in that movie where the kid
disappears and like the aliens abducted
him it's like the people start
forgetting the kid existed and then
slowly the things are disappearing like
the woman was it Julian Moore or
whatever she like sees evidence the kid
is she's like there it's there and then
also like the picture disappears she's
like what happened
panthera says the Andrew Tate story is
real both brothers are self-confessed
scammers there are two highly
comprehensive threats compiling evidence
that their alleged trafficking operation
is real I mean look I've seen videos
where he basically says he wanted to
make money so he told these women who
loved him he was going to have them do
cam work and they got to pay him I don't
know what those videos are because it
could be out of context I'm just saying
I saw those videos
some of them are creepy
but uh I just I try to be careful
because I don't trust the establishment
to be honest you know
King Generations has pray for Demar
Hamlin of the Buffalo Bills we have an
update on that
I'm looking into it right now um the
Family Guy thing looks like it's Peter
on the phone with a girl when he says it
he says what I give me back my son
there's a cutaway gag where it's like
Harrison Ford running down the street
grabbing people I didn't see that part
yet I'll have to look into it he like
runs up someone grabs him give her back
my son then he throws him then he runs
again grab someone give me back my son
and throws him and they run over someone
yeah
where are we at with some super jets
agamemnon's gym bag says finishing a
cutting board as a Christmas gift for a
friend who tried to Gaslight me on the
2020 riots at this point I haven't
gotten her to denounce the National Park
Service but she's coming around here's
your reminder not to give up on those
you care about well I guess Luke would
call her a dirty communist but you know
absolutely wait what happened he said I
haven't been able to convince her to
denounce the National Park Service but
she's coming around you could do this I
believe in you and those dirty
Communists need to be put in checkments
oh man
can block passed away in a snowmobile
accident yeah and so what 40 is saying
yeah and then Jeremy Renner ran himself
over oh man how's he doing he was he
lost a lot of blood critical but stable
condition hopefully his leg's okay
that's brutal with what did he run and
stuff over he had a big snow plow he ran
his leg over Jesus I heard his neighbor
gave him a tourniquet yeah saved his
life so if you guys have tourniquets
learn how to use them because you never
know when you're going to need to use
those well you can just make a
tourniquet of course yeah if you do a
two-time they're also very like they're
also very cheap a pen and a shirt yeah
you should learn how to do it I did a
hostile environment training and it's
surprising that there are like some
people will put the tourniquet like
below the wound I know it doesn't it's
lightweight what yeah
yeah also you have to usually go really
pretty tighter like way tighter than you
think you would yeah there's a time
limit too yeah a certain amount of time
because the the tissue starts dying and
depends what kind of vein or artery
artery is being connected yeah correct
yeah we had one guy they showed a pig
from a royal bleed and a guy just hit
the floor
he had a what's it called something
nerve reaction
I don't know what it's called a stress
response no no it's there's a nerve um
you want to look it up the vagus nerve
vagus nerve yeah vagal nervous is that
what it was Vegas nerve I think don't
look that up I think that's what it is
people are probably going to correct me
and tell me what it was but yeah like
the guy told us before he showed us the
video of the bleed some of you may pass
out just be from the side of the blood
because your blood pressure your blood
pressure drops and so this dude just he
was sitting in a metal chair we all were
and then all of a sudden we just heard a
bang he just flopped off the chair and
then what happened was the trainer
lifted his legs up to put push the blood
pressure back to his head and then he
comes too and tries getting up and the
guy yells at him don't move and he goes
no no I'm fine he goes no you're not
don't move he's like the only reason
you're conscious is because I've lifted
your legs up to put the blood back in
your head it was crazy the tenth cranial
nerve the vagus nerve and it's like uh
it's directly interfaces with the
parasympathetic control the heart lungs
and digestive tract so I can see why
that getting squeezed or open what is it
dilates like is that what happened when
someone sees blood it's like a fight or
flight it's just all the blood goes down
to your your
essential organs or something it's like
dosing you know those goats that freeze
yeah scare them they like lock up and
then they fall over it's like those
things are gonna get eaten yeah it's
easier to herd them though because like
make a loud bang pop a balloon and they
all freeze or whatever
all right the devil in God are raging
inside me says right now in the Buffalo
Bills game one of their defensive
players made a tackle he got up and then
fell to the ground the medical staff
have been administering CPR for the past
nine minutes we we heard that he got
tackled uh he got tackled
so where the latest information is that
he was rushed to a hospital and we still
don't know exactly what is you know
happening I want to talk about some of
that stuff I got a lot I got a lot to
talk about with that stuff let's let's
do that members only because we're gonna
get we'll get spicy spend with the
factory files coming out this will be
really really interesting all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends become a member
at timcast.com like I said
what we want to do is I want to make a
real product for you guys so we have
cast Castle we've got you know and we're
trying to pick things up it's just it's
it's organizational power which makes it
very very difficult
but we've got the members only shows for
you it costs money when you watch those
videos it's not free to host those we
pay the bandwidth and you watch it
that's why we you know make it a paid
thing but also we we sell the product we
use the revenue generated to invest and
expand the business and I don't care
about owning an infinity pool I care
about setting up these coffee shops
around the country setting up venues
where people can come together that's
one of the things I care about I care
about this this uh fact-checking
non-profit we're setting up that um we
are we have to register in every single
state and right now I think we're
registered in like three we're gonna
we're this year I believe we're ready to
go and um we may have our federal uh
information which means tax-exempt
status so we're going to start looking
for donors I'm not going to take any
money or be involved in any capacity
other than like oversight
but we're going to hire people to do
fact checking to build a fact a fact
checking
um browser extension to rate news
agencies and things like that really
excited for that this is the stuff that
I'm looking forward to building and with
your help as members we're going to do
more of that so become a member at
timcast.com you can follow the show at
timcastirl everywhere follow us on
Instagram and follow at timcast news on
Twitter WE Post articles every day you
can follow me at timcast hi do you want
to shout anything out
um yeah so um lives of tick tock on
every social Channel and if you go to
lives of techtalk.com we have a sub
stack there where we post some longer
articles that have more research more
investigative stuff and feel free to
become a subscriber to help us continue
doing what we're doing well yeah that
was great thank you so much for coming
on uh thank you for providing your
perspective and uh not being afraid to
show your face it really means a lot to
a lot of people so thank you so much for
doing that my website is Luke
uncensored.com I did a video today that
was titled this is how you need to think
in 2023 and I think it's worth watching
for the tough times ahead I'm doing an
AMA on Lucan sensor.com this Thursday
where I will have to answer your
questions Lucan sensor.com see you there
thank you again so much for having me
it's spelled Chaya but it's pronounced
yeah it's more like h-a-y-a with a
c-h-a-y-a okay it means life in Hebrew
is there is there a word that describes
the sound like is there a way to
describe that pronunciation no there is
that I don't think so maybe in Cyrillic
I think there might be one of those in
Cyrillic well not won't take up
anybody's time uh hey before I go I do
want to mention I brought this up
earlier this uh Rogan Joe Rogan
interviewed a guy named Siddhartha Cara
and this guy went to the Congo
undercover and exposed tens of thousands
of humans digging up Cobalt for your
electric vehicle batteries you want to
talk about electric vehicles being
sustainable these they say that there
are no Artisans there working they tell
people they tell they've been telling us
there are no humans on the ground
digging that is all Machinery you see
tens of thousands like 15 000 humans
including kids digging with their bare
hands breathing in toxic Cobalt and it
has to get out so watch that interview
with Joe Rogan and Siddhartha Kaya thank
you Siddhartha for doing that thank you
Kyle for coming again thanks for having
me and uh Serge yeah that was a good one
I enjoyed it thanks for coming I
appreciate it that's actually G in Dutch
in Afrikaans so it's like it's like why
Arabic I can say a lot of things same
thing it's just a different word
different letter but just a g it's
pretty simple yeah
all right we'll see you all over at
timcast.com welcome to 2023 it's going
to get wild yeah go to timcast.com and
we'll see y'all there happy New Year